[Music]
foreign
thank you
[Music]
foreign
wow that's amazing puzzles
[Music]
there are 72 084 different possible
positions after two moves nine million
different possible positions after three
moves
318 billion different possible positions
after four moves I'm gonna play the
London seriously I'm sorry
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
land of fjords Majestic mountains Cliffs
and waterfalls
in addition to stunning geography Norway
is home to the greatest chess player who
has ever lived Magnus Carlson
since 2013 Norway has also hosted one of
the strongest chess super tournaments in
the world and it is one for which Magnus
has claimed the top prize in the last
four years
can anyone stop him
this time he'll meet one of his toughest
Challenges ever at his home tournament
with nine Rivals all hungry to beat the
best
from Carlson's fiercest online rival
today in their first classical
over-the-board battle in nearly four
years Hikaru Nakamura
to the young star Carlson once
hand-picked as his most worthy
Championship opponent alireza farrugia
two more young stars are trying to
follow in his footsteps laude Beck Abdul
sotorov and kukesh domaraju
two established stars have already won a
Super tournament in 2023. Anish giri and
Fabiano caruana
two more long-time Headliners seek to
take their next turn Atop A major
tournament Wesley so and Shakira Mahmoud
yarov
finally Carlson's Countryman and friend
ariantari rounds out the field who will
come out on top will Carlson run the
table yet again or will someone else
usurp the throne this
is Norway chess
welcome to round six of Norway chess and
it might be peaceful outside in
Stavanger but inside the arena of Norway
chess a storm is brewing after
yesterday's unexpected result the
competition has been thrown wide open
setting the stage for some thrilling
battles I'm your host International
Master Ivanka houska and as always it's
a great pleasure to be here calling the
action alongside legendary Grandmaster
Judith Polgar and the Magnificent
Grandmaster and commentator David Howell
and Judith after yesterday's unexpected
result the competition has been blasted
wide open what can we expect from the
players
well we can see that more than half of
the tournament is over right so this is
uh this is going to be something very
very interesting coming up
it was very interesting to see how
Fabiano drowned versus momentarov and at
the same time he lost heavily it was
very painful for him but he was such a
lead ahead of the others that even now
he's ahead with one point so if he can
recover and his mindset is right then it
means that he should be still extremely
happy to be in the lead
and get ready to play today get ready to
play today and uh David when it comes to
the tournament is now in the final
stages does this mean the players are
gonna now start taking risks they
certainly have to especially that
chasing pack who are hunting down uh
Carolina now Atop The leaderboard it's
still wide open nine of the players
could still feasibly win the tournament
but they have to win in the classical
Armageddon won't cut the mustard right
now it's all about taking risks and uh
for those who pays off uh the risks yeah
I think everything is still possible
everything is still possible and after
yesterday's results
well there was a lot of emotion at stake
as Judith highlighted because Fabiano
Carolina did crash out to a superb
Shakura mamajarov are the results Magnus
Carlson defeating Anish giri and the
Armageddon portion what other results
Judith interested you the most about
yesterday for me it was very interesting
to see Hikaru how he was determined to
win in a classical again because he knew
that mama jarov is going to give a good
fight for Fabiano and whatever happens
there I know that Nakamura is following
all the other games pretty heavily but
still he knew that this round can be the
moment for him I believe and he knew
that the underdog is doing pretty badly
it was his birthday maybe he did not
know about that I don't know but you
feel it when you still want to fight for
the first place you know that the other
one your rival has to lose but you have
to score the full point and he knew it
he was playing uh tricky opening well
not so tricky but it was a slow opening
but somehow he outplayed tari in a very
very convincing way I must say yeah and
David any of the Armageddon results that
kept you entertained yeah all of the
armageddon's that's the beauty of no HS
first of all we should mention Magnus
winning yet another Armageddon he's won
all of his Armageddon so far four out of
the five rounds so far beating
anishagiri yesterday great stuff from
Magnus but also good cash just really
confident really just efficient taking
down Abdus tour of yesterday for me that
was maybe the Armageddon of the round
yeah and they might only have been two
decisive results in the classical but
there were a lot of movement in the
standings because we did see Fabiano
caruana maintain his lead but it has
been shortened significantly because
Hikaru Nakamura with that classical win
did leave up to nine and a half points
out of 15 just one point away from
Fabiana caruana alireza that is there
seven and a half points but get this
from nine to first place is only a four
point four and a half Point difference
which means anything can and anything
will happen and uh talking about action
let's have a look at today's matchups
because we're in for a treat as always
it's Norway chess and a headlining there
we can see orientari playing White
against Magnus Carlson and Judith which
matchup are you eagerly anticipating I
think the most I'm interested about
alireza playing against Hikaru because
Hikaru is heated up for a fight and he
knows that he's just right behind
Fabiano and they are real Rivals you can
feel it in his interviews also that he
would really like to catch Fabiano so
that is definitely the game of the round
for me but of course Fabiano against not
your back is something I think will be
extremely interesting as well and for
you David I know it's very difficult to
choose yeah it's difficult all of the
matchups will be exciting of course but
Ivanka we're in Norway I live in Norway
now I'm looking forward to that
Norwegian Derby between Aryan tari and
Marcus Carlson Magnus with black he
really needs to win if he has any
aspirations of winning the tournament so
uh big day for him certainly a big day
for Magnus he will have to take some
risks because he's playing black and of
course it's Norway chess and Norway
chess has a very fighting format it
pushes chess to its boundaries it's a 10
player single round robin 120 minutes
for the entire game sounds like a lot it
really isn't and there is only a 10
second increment added after move 40 and
in the case of a draw this is where
things get very special because the
players will then have to play an
Armageddon game to break the tie and of
course Fighting Chess means no draw
offer before move 30
and as David and Judith have highlighted
the players do need to start winning
their classical games and there we see
alireza faruja and Hikaru Nakamura
gearing up for their fight now it's very
interesting because when we came into
this tournament Ali Reza was ranked
number two in the world and then this
position went to Fabiana Carona after
his magnificent start and according to
the stats this that that position has
actually moved over to Hikaru Nakamura
who's now number two for the first time
since 2015. so it's more than just an
OHS it's a matter of Pride right
yeah the live ratings they're shifting
every single day and uh yeah who will be
world number two at the end of this
tournament it's Up For Debate we have
all the best players here in the world
and that will be a fruity Clash uh if uh
farage is showed us anything to go by
but uh here we see go cash against Gary
also this one is going to be hard for it
of course both players have impressed at
times in this event
yes and I see go cash being more mature
from day to day because yesterday for
example he made a draw in the classical
game against the other youngster not
here back but in the playoff in the
Armageddon I was kind of surprised that
first of all he was a huge Advantage out
of the opening so that was something he
was very fortunate with that but he did
not take the winning opportunity later
on when he was much better he was just
going for Perpetual track or it was a
repetition of moves just to score the
point so that's you usually the case
when you're very experienced 15 years of
high-class tournament behind you but
he's only 17 and he does this very
professional attitude I'm very
professional a good horse never jumps as
higher higher than it has to
just doing the minimum that's enough
impressive professional stuff and then
they say you've got to work smart and oh
players have started and there we see
the cash and farrugia make their opening
moves
and
what have they played are we looking at
D4 Pawn openings I think so when it
comes to kakash wow and uh here we see
that battle between world number two and
world number three farooja and Hikaru
Nakamura and it's the Sicilian a bit of
a shock dude we'd love to see it of
course a fighting opening but Hikaru
nearly
kind of without fail opens with E5 these
days he's mixing it up showing that he
wants to win as black potentially
well it's uh it it is an interesting
decision but well maybe he became more
Brave after seeing the live rating list
it's it's true that hikara tends to open
with the Berlin defense that's his
favorite but I have seen Hikaru also
experiment with the Kalashnikov he did
it against Dominguez and also against
Wesley so in the American Cup will we
see the same no it's going to be a Rosa
limo
alireza keeping the position closed
what are we gonna see from alirez is he
gonna capture the Knight is he gonna
Castle what do we think I think it's
also something that Nakamura probably
decided that he wants to little bit
provoke alireza because olureza is an
incredible player with interesting ideas
and expected ideas so he wouldn't mind
to have a very tough game because he
knows it if he really wants to win the
tournament he has to score a classical
game
so he has to win and he wants to give a
chance of course he knows it that it's
going to be a huge battle
but he just doesn't want to go to the
extreme solid things and uh on the
subject of Hikari
he actually before playing this game had
a chat with our reporter svera so let's
hear what Hikaru had to say
what is the most difficult getting to
the playing board or sitting at the
playing board today
um I mean obviously I've gotten used for
the last couple years there are a lot
more fans of Chester used to be
certainly whether it's like in a playing
atmosphere or just in general want him
out um but I think it's a good thing for
chess in general that they're more fans
and so I enjoy all this I mean sometimes
it can be a bit much before the games
but overall it's it's not positive so I
don't mind signing autographs or taking
pictures
black against Borussia today it seems
like a very important game for the
leaderboard and how the table is looking
right now is that something that
concerns you or are you just kind of
focus on
doing what shows up on the board you
know I think if this was maybe a normal
scoring format where it's like one for a
win and half point for a draw I think
you know maybe I would think it's quite
important but I think certainly in this
format where you have a winning
classical being worth three and then say
you you draw a game when an Armageddon
something along these lines being one
and a half points uh I sort of feel like
you just play it one game at a time and
see what happens and as I've said before
if other players just win every game in
classical there's nothing you can do
about it but you just try to focus on
playing playing playing good moves and
if you play good moves good things
should happen we look forward to it
Curry thank you sure thanks
and there we see Hikaru giving his
thoughts surrounded by children and we
fast see chess becoming more and more
popular in Norway I know one thing that
it's kind of a New Year tradition that
once the new year celebration's over you
go and watch the world rapid and Blitz
on TV every family now in Norway does
this and as a result
Magnus and Aryan have a lot of
supporters wow I didn't know this that
it got to this point in Norway that's
fantastic I met these kids out there and
they were really enthusiastic rooting
for uh Magnus and when I said if it's
not Magnus they said for Hikaru
but it's great that we we see such a
young children already rooting for
professional players it's not only that
they like the game to play just on
Scholastic level but I could feel that
they they really follow the sport yes
absolutely and interesting enough
whenever I bump into people and I'm
asked you know what I do and I tell them
chess player they'll say ah I've been
watching Hikaru streams so Hikaru
massively growing the game and there we
can see are we surprised by the opening
I think the opening progressed along
very kind of traditional Parts until
this last couple of Night Moves during
nights on the rim are dim they plays
surely they've heard that phrase before
Knight to A3 I mean Knight to H6 is
maybe more traditional in this type of
uh set up the night the Black Knight
often goes back via F7 but uh strange
developments you would think yes this is
what I was uh thinking at first as well
that night to go to H6 somehow it's more
regular for black than to go Knight A3
with white
but um it's interesting because after
Knight C4 black will be playing D5 right
so that must be not an immediate plan
for white
but maybe he went to A3 because he plans
to go C3 and D4 and on a later stage to
come to C4
yeah and uh according to the database
available to me at least Knight to A3
was the first new move at least at this
high level a bit of a novelty there and
it didn't surprise Hikaru Hikaru very
quickly playing Knight to H6 this means
that most likely it's just computer
suggestions and it's up to for usual now
to back up the fact that his Knight is
sitting on the edge of the board as you
mentioned that just the Black Knight
often gets back after a move like F6 or
maybe even F5 the Black Knight gets into
the game uh just Retreats back to F7
hey I'm trying to think of some fruit
puns uh here just looking at alaris's
shirt the fashion designer Hikaru I
think we saw in the feature chat earlier
Hikaru loves his pineapple shirt maybe
this is far Asia's kind of special
preparation right exactly the Mind Games
have begun it's nearly perfect perfect
I think he's wearing oranges on his
shirt I can't think of any orange puns
uh you can have nice apple and pears
right that's an Express yeah that's
that's a kind of a English expression
apples and pears oh yeah we've uh I've
just been fed a pun from the producer
aren't you glad he's wearing that shirt
orange you glad oh that's
my delivery was not great that
it's no fake deal I don't know
we'll get better ones a bit later in the
day
what else I'm still impressed that they
managed to come up with that on the spot
watch that man go no oh anyway back to
the chest well alireza is deep in
thought here at move eight yeah
oh but it's interesting to see alireza
like he's really thinking the way that
maybe he's out of book right
it's strange though to be out of book
when he was the one who chose this
variation as white he's just played
Knight A3 himself
either that was freestyling or it's a
new new move that he studied but also at
the same time maybe he was expecting E5
so I'm not sure he he was ready in his
mindset that Nakamura will be choosing
the Sicilian yeah true I saw a great
putt on the screen he should have played
one before because then it's the a
Rancher Tang opening I know and the
irony of it actually is that Ali Reza
was playing 1v4 in the Blitz
yeah
but he didn't commit the crime and for
those Edgar Allah pones fans they will
understand
it was the orangutan that did it you
guys haven't read out not since I was
about 12 years old
but I loved another one uh he's the
juicer today alireza is the juicer oh
very good very good
shout out to Hikaru and his streams but
yeah meanwhile I think let's do a
Roundup of the other openings this one
is uh yet to proceed I think once white
decides what to do with the center maybe
C3 D4 most likely uh then we'll come
back to this and discuss the plans still
very standard stuff so far
and uh okay taking a look at the bird's
eye view I can see a few positions that
are catching my eye
which ones are catching yours dude
I was just looking for a second the
tari's game how they are the
developments are going on versus Magnus
and it's interesting that Magnus played
Siciliano so it seems like it's a
sicilian day
and but it was a three Bishop B5 very
solid play by tari and of course for
Tori it would be very important not to
lose today because it was a very painful
loss yesterday and somehow he should
start scoring more and more points right
so this is a kind of an understandable
decision that he wants to go on the
solid way but after that he played the
blackplate Knight D7 which is more for
looking for a longer game not exchanging
the bishop on D7
so I think it's going to be later on a
more complicated game black will develop
Knight F6 plus A6 B5 probably Bishop to
developed the B7 E6 or G6 but I'm
expecting an interesting middle game
there
yeah so it didn't kind of start as the
open open Sicilian but kind of the
themes will be very uh kind of similar
reminiscent of the open Sicilian now
that white has played this move d4 and
Judith you mentioned as black Magnus
Hikaru they're playing the Sicilian they
want to win of course how hard is it to
win on demand as black because uh for
Magnus this could be Mako break time
well generally I think to win
on demand it's already very difficult
and I'm not sure exactly when you play
against the lower rated or lower level
player like now Atari versus Magnus
whether it's such a big difference
whether you're black or white
but I think for Magnus it he likes
challenges and I think it might be
something that it forces him to to come
up with some interesting original maybe
even suspicious ideas just to create
something a messy position and we have
G6 on the board which is logical that he
wants to be more sharp with having a
fair and Chateau bishop and provoking a
little bit tari but of course it's never
easy to to win on demand and especially
I think Magnus is having more and more
pressure on him that he he really fails
it that something is not working on his
way and I was kind of surprised and
worried when yesterday he went to the
confessional booth and he admitted that
he blundered that specific move and he
thought that he's much better in that
position so there was a misjudgment I
think in the position it's true that he
was difficult or more saying that it was
dangerous for for Anish but somehow it
somehow Slipped Away in his hand right
and that was not a good sign for Magnus
so I'm pretty sure that he's somehow
trying to find himself to to win not
only to win a game but somehow to feel
that I play well and I I really do it
the the way that people will say and I
can say that it's the Magnus way
a question
um when it comes to risk taking
do you guys have a special formula
because I've commented alongside David
and I'm maybe going to put words into
his mouth but I've heard him say many
times you've got to keep the pieces on
the board you've got to make sure that
there's a lot of tension did you do you
have anything
for example yesterday we've seen
something like this between Nakamura and
tari because yes that's kind of a
strategy that you want to keep on the
border pieces it's not necessarily that
you're even having with white big
Advantage probably you cannot have
simply but I think it's uh it's very
important to keep the position a lot of
pieces you have to make plans decisions
phone structures how to do it so this
this is why many people start one night
F3 when they have to win there was this
famous game between kaspar of carp of 87
world championship match when carpool
was leading 12 to 11 and there was a
mastering situation for Gary Kasparov
and he knew that there is no way that he
was going to be winning just like that
he has to play a long exhausting game
and then
its nerves and luck
okay I'm gonna put you both on the spot
what openings would you both play when
you're on a must win situation for the
black pieces
well against what okay so if I go E4 as
a exactly like Magnus has faced I think
it depends against who I'm playing with
because if I know exactly what opening
someone who you know who's going to be
solid lower rated than you solid
well probably I don't go into sharp
lines or very concrete lines I try to
avoid and maybe even take a
verse position if I really have to have
to have to win yeah because often we've
seen my players like play the modern
that kind of kind of very tense cagey
game
would you do the same
no I don't know because I to tell you
the truth I retired 10 years ago 100
years ago so chess is becoming a lot
different I think it's very important
somehow to understand your opponent also
what he is up to or she yeah
yeah and uh you know me Ivanka like I
said just anything to keep the pieces on
uh I normally I react to 184 with E5 for
example but against certain opponents
you can't really do that and hope for a
game so um yeah these days maybe the
French the caracana modern something
just a bit cagey like you say just full
of tension and the questions for me to
answer but also for the opponent and I
think that's what Magnus is doing here
it's the Sicilian of course but he's
just keeping pieces on the board and
it's kind of a hybrid now looks a bit
like the dragon Sicilian potentially
once the Black Knight comes out to F6
Blackwell castle and white is chosen a
more positional line because white has
castled kingside himself and at least
it's a game it's a fresh position but
maybe I wouldn't be surprised if iftario
would have this idea to play C4 some
maruti kind of setup with Knight E3
Bishop E3 and even giving up the fight
Square Bishop because that is something
hard to crack right
depends very much on his mood I think
yeah what do you think Ariana's mood
will be it's been a tough few days for
him uh three classical losses in a row
now
lock the game down simplify as much as
possible I mean he did this last year
with great success
I predict more the same and I think
Judah is right that he will perhaps
reach for that c2c4 line at the same
time it's extremely difficult to make a
draw if you really want to make it draw
so it's it's very tricky what mindset
should you be having I think the best is
if you really want to make a draw you
can you have to choose
what type of position you want to go to
and you're not ready to take risky
decisions if there is whenever you have
an option to go solid you go solid but
you have to have this strategy but the
fact that you want to make a draw let's
say it is a very dangerous strategy that
you're just always looking for
equalizing always looking for a draw
because of course against Magnus and
against strong players just because the
position is equal it does not mean at
all that it's going to be a draw and for
example which day was it yesterday you
know day before day before when tari
played versus so
he had this Marshall Gambit and then
he did not really get a bad position or
worse but he went into some very passive
play and he I think he just wanted to
make a draw but then he ended up in a
little bit unpleasant position and
Wesley was pressing but okay he did not
make any serious mistake that he would
drown but this happens very often when
you really want to make a draw and you
don't calculate you're just making moves
generally it's good enough it seems good
and then you can easily you can easily
make those passive decisions as a very
very important psychological point and I
remember I think it was a quote from
Vichy in his book mind master who said
there's nothing worse than needing a
draw being close to the drawer but that
draw not being there
out just Out Of Reach we've been there
in that situation
yeah that's the thing in chess if you
put a draw as being like the height of
Mount Everest like you've climbed that
mountain then
yeah if you don't make it
ah it's uh it's just you can't get back
from that and yeah I don't think you
want to start any game as you said dude
with that negative mindset especially
with white it's so easy to go wrong and
actually in this tournament black has
won 60 of the decisive classical games
so that shows yeah having the white
pieces not necessarily a safety net yeah
but you know it's very interesting I
think Vichy is one of the guys who is so
strict like he knows it exactly if you
want to make a draw don't pretend to do
something no you want to draw you're not
hiding it from anybody
everybody can see it you just go for it
exchange everything and it's a draw
don't think that okay I want to draw but
I also want to play and I don't want it
to be so transparent no I want a draw I
want to draw and the ones actually I did
this to to Vichy because we played
incredible interesting games and at one
point I got somehow you uh fed off with
the fact that we made incredible
interesting games but somehow the end of
it it was that way she went oh and then
I thought I was playing in Dortmund I
remember and I felt that he he knows
this that tough game complicated game a
lot of calculation it's huge mess
everything and at the end he wins so he
played the dragon and I played
simplifying everything I was just
exchanging this Knight D5 exchanging the
Queens the Bishops everything so he was
kind of frustrated that we had the 17
move draw and well I was not hiding it
that I want to draw that's all and after
that I could win against him in the next
tournament so I stopped him but yeah if
you want to have a draw then focus it
don't don't try to trick yourself and
the audience go for it if you have the
option but of course this is an opening
with Magnus that of course you cannot
simplify the position and go for it
completely it's only that he's going to
play solidly today yeah and uh talking
about solid starts
um should we pay a visit to Norberg
Abdus Turf against Fabiano caruana
because there the game looks very tense
also looks very mainstream as well
how is Fabiana doing and what would you
advise him to recall you know to recover
from yesterday's painful loss because
he's still at the top of the standings
should he hold firm with the black
pieces in this game
and uh hedge his bets in Armageddon or
let it flow and see what comes I think
the the best thing he he had to do is to
to fix his mindset the way that just
let's look at the time the cross table I
say ah I'm number one I have a one point
lead perfect so I play a normal game so
not the fact the the game itself so if
he can he could get to that mindset that
he still has a fantastic tournament so
far then everything is under control
from his end yeah I totally agree just
stem the bleeding make sure things don't
spiral out of control it was just one
bad day but he's had several great days
uh Fabiano uh we can definitely tell as
you mentioned Ivanka is changing
approach though his last black game he
played this fiery French against uh uh
farouzia and now against another
teenager he's kind of locked it down
it's the Berlin uh variation of the
Antebellum so we've only seen one set of
Peace trades so far but very solid stuff
and yeah it's all about whether white at
some point can break with a move like D4
uh you often need to prepare this with
several moves and meanwhile black is
very solid Black's night will go back
eventually black will Castle the king
most likely on the king side but can
sometimes go Queen side and it's a lot
of maneuvering ahead Judith did you ever
have this type of position in your
career no I was not a big fan of playing
this kind of close position and giving
up the Bishops and exchanging on C6 so
um
I think I wouldn't be happy to play it
with either colors
it is it is a very slow maneuvering I
mean B6 I'm not sure I I completely
understand why was this important but
probably it's just that black has time
he does not have to rush with the castle
he does not have to rush with with
Knight D7
probably he's going to be playing A5
also maybe Knight A5 or something that
he might be
yeah worried a little bit but but in
these positions there are so many small
things happening right and many of the
games end up in a very equilish position
and they lead to a draw also so here you
have to have a lot of patience and you
have to be appreciating every little
sign of maybe I can get a more pleasant
position kind of attitude it's not that
you have Advantage really it's just
maneuvering and you feel happy you're
maneuvering back and forth with your
knight and whether D4 will be possible
on B3 I'm not crazy to see the Knight to
be honest
I was just gonna say something quite
interesting so um B6
isn't
a main move at all in fact it's only
been played once before
and the main line is actually to retreat
the Knight to D7 and then the White
Knight Will Spring to G5 and then there
will be some trades so this is probably
why nordeback has now gone into the tank
and is thinking about Fabiano's plans I
mean Fabiano is also I mean he's so
famous for his prep right it's like his
reputation precedes him so is that that
as well going on in the background
you have certainly uh Fabiano is an
expert on these types of positions with
white as well as black so he knows kind
of what is potentially a bit annoying
for the black setup how to pose problems
there but he also knows Black's best and
most solid defenses and I really like
this move as Judith says kind of cutting
out the white note which wanted to go to
the edge of the board to attack this
Pawn on B7 that's gone and uh yeah if I
think if given the opportunity Fabi
might even keep white guessing here if
I'm making a move like Queen E7 and
hinting that he might even Castle Queen
side with the black king where he has a
lot of Pawn shelter uh so okay Knight G5
on the board you're back a typical idea
it is it is a typical idea he also could
have perhaps also exploded open in the
center with D4 but that would have left
to a completely different type of game
so wow I like this uh chat comment pavi
doesn't play chess chess plays through
Fabi
great quote but you know it's
interesting that in these kind of
positions it's important to understand
that for the top guys who are working on
this kind of position analyzing I mean
it seems like it's just a position
nothing concrete and maybe some people
think that the players are not working
out in details these lines but actually
they do so the reason is because they
have to understand the details of it
what happens what changes in a position
once you play B6 or even C5 maybe or
what happens when you play H6 or can you
Castle already earlier or for example in
the previous movie Black would have
played Knight D7 then Knight G5 is
something that definitely the black
Bishop would be captured and this way
sometimes this B6 kind of moves is a
waiting move which can be useful for
later use but actually black is waiting
in which direction white would like to
be going is he going H3 then there is a
weakness maybe H6 G5 can happen before
four black castles right and if not G5
now black has the opportunity to move
away with the bishop to G4 or
immediately to D7 if he wants so there
are positions and situations in the slow
motion game that you're just making
waiting moves and you trying to get the
information out of your opponent that
what is your plan
we've played these positions
more from the Black s than the white uh
kind of my entire career and I'm just
freestyling most of the time but I have
noticed that there is this trend top
players even if there's just all these
kind of this vast array of choice they
know the details they know all those
nuances and I've played several games
against the especially the younger
generation when to me it looks like okay
every position is the same but they're
like oh if you had done this I would
have done this if you would have done
this and they go so deep and uh I mean
it's very impressive in these
maneuvering positions where you would
think the engines aren't uh kind of so
valuable the computer input there but
yeah they know their stuff they've
checked it all and I wouldn't be
surprised if Fabio makes a quick
decision with his Bishop yeah for
example in the Berlin I remember when
kramnik started to play it and he
brought into fashion uh when he won the
match against Kasparov and if you if our
audience also knows this uh this uh
Queen exchange where the king is on the
eighth and then there is a strategical
thing if are you playing Rook D1 check
pushing back the king to A8 or you're
allowing the black king to go to B7 in
principle you can wait this way or that
way but still you have to make a
decision how you want to have the game
going in the next 20 30 40 moves because
it just goes to a completely different
way the game and here also sometimes
it's small things but strategically just
going to a different area
and let's check out maybe some of the
other action in the meantime this uh
this game is going to enter a slower
phase I'm expecting the black Bishop to
move uh black wants to keep the bishop
pair no reason to kind of allow that
trade when you have a slightly worse
Pawn structure so where next to go I'm
looking at some exciting games can I
direct you to the good cash and ichigiri
game just from Pure selfishness because
I actually play this opening myself with
white I want to see what happened and I
want to see whether good cash has gotten
a good position I was also
uh picking on that game yeah this game
has progressed far quicker than a lot of
the other games which are still within
the first 10 moves this one's out at
moose 17 already look at the white uh
King it's actually castled Queen side of
course actually when I first started
playing chess I thought the king castled
queen side onto B1 and The Rook came
over to see one but uh it took me a
while to realize you go to C1 and then
step over to B1 take the next remove and
then the Rook has actually moved over to
C1 as well so white spent a lot of time
there but uh should we do an action
replay yes from the start and it's
interesting that our Niche was spending
la then five minutes so far
yeah less than five minutes and 17 moves
on the board D4 D5 Ivanka you mentioned
you play this opening uh it starts out
as the slav and the variation where
white just blocks things just slowly
with E3 and Bishop F5 and uh of course
we see this is one of the most trendy
variations in chess right now the White
Knight hunts down this black Bishop
actually if white doesn't play this then
black pretty much has a London system
with colors reversed and therefore a
very healthy solid position so white
hunts down the bishop pair and
eventually this bishop drops back we see
Queen to B3 hitting the B7 Pawn this is
the one downside behind developing
Black's C8 Bishop early and after Queen
C7 the move Castle Queen side if this
bishop was allowed to live then this
would be a precarious decision with the
King on C1 but of course this bishop on
G6 will not survive too much longer it
will get traded off after a trade of
Pawns here A6 preparing a pawn storm on
the queen side we see the trade at King
B1 and the black porn star advancing and
after d takes C5 rather than a recapture
black improves his Knight festival and
this is the current position after Rook
C1 Knight to E5
interesting last move maybe unexpected
last move trying to jump into C4
and what do we make of this because you
mentioned anisha's played Super quickly
Judith but kukesh has been the one
burning time he spent almost half an
hour up to this point so maybe out of
book here is white
very interesting position I must admit
to have the king zombie one in this
position and white has an extra opponent
the C5 Pawn somehow looks like not weak
at all
but I'm pretty sure that black wants to
take it back in a later stage and yes
indeed Knight we'll come to C4 I believe
the question how white wants to develop
with his pieces with especially the F1
Bishop
if Queen F2 seems to me that it's uh
it's possible to move away to open up
the diagonal for the bishop
or also I'm thinking whether can white
play E4 and activate the D2 Bishop
I'm just going to give you an extra
piece of general information there was
only really one game in the database not
with night not the Knight coming to E5
but I was played just now by Goo cash
with the white pieces against arvind and
their cash one
so this is clearly something that Anish
has prepared okay so it was following
that game until 95 yeah wow novelty by
Anish Gary but this makes it even more
interesting why Anish was thinking uh
not any sorry gokash was spending so
much time until this point was he
unaware of what what Anish has in mind
of course is it something that he's
surprised he's suspicious what can he
have in the preparation I thought my
game was okay and what can go wrong so
you have this hesitation in your brain
right when you think that something went
okay and your opponent is just flashing
out the moves as I know what I'm doing
I'm gonna show it yeah maybe it's the
anticipation as well he knew every move
something's going to happen a bomb is
going to be dropped on him Anish is not
going to copy that game that black had
previously lost unless he had a specific
idea in mind and finally we reached this
moment where Anish has revealed the idea
on the face of things it looks like it
should be healthy for white to me at
least we have the bishop power we have
an extra Pawn but and how to get pieces
out is the white king going to be safe
on this flank on B1 long term that's the
question Knight C4 coming like you said
Judah sometimes B4 will come black can
just simply Castle bring Rooks to the
center right I would also consider with
white to play Bishop E1 and regroup it
to G3 for example or even Bishop E1 G4
and Bishop G3 can be something
interesting
it makes a lot of sense and uh well we
have a move from gookash
he's I was gonna say you came up with a
beautiful idea of relocating the bishop
to a better diagonal and good cash has
just spoiled it and there we can see it
has been awarded by game review a
mistake
who says it's a mistake the game review
the All-Seeing computer says
not perfect chess my friend
so making the position slightly worse as
we see there the definition of the
question mark and I guess Black's Knight
is simply going to jump into the square
it wanted to use anyway the C4 square is
a great launching pad and it looks like
anisha's surprise maybe paying off at
this early stage of course nothing too
drastic it's not a blunder it's not a
kind of a losing mistake or anything but
how does this help do we think Judith
what is the idea in mind because kukesh
knows and he's going to plant his Knight
into C4 that's an automatic we'll see
him play it instantly no other good
Square for the night on the board now so
you see the bishop will end up on E1
anyway
kind of assist Ing and speeding up the
opponent's plan
strange you've got to think F4 looks
like a useful move but is it really
necessary
I would be afraid to have F4 move for
the reason that if let's say Bishop
moves away later at some point there
could be some unpleasant thing for white
if well of course it's a very much for
later idea but to play B4 somehow and
Knight comes to E4 which of course is
not easy yet because the C4 Knight is
under attack but let's say if the bishop
would be not moving away then Knight
takes D2 B4 Knight comes to E4 then
black would get some activation and I
also think that you know what can be a
nice idea for black without making costs
playing Rook H5 maybe and bring the Rook
to the queen side that way nice nice
full board Vision there it looks like
anisha's position is full of promise and
really tense right now go cash has to
recover from this opening surprise but
still early days of course
still early days I think it's the
perfect time to take our first break but
in the meantime don't miss your chance
to win a diamond membership this Friday
the chess.com Discord server is hosting
an arena with four Diamond memberships
up for grabs to stake your claim join
the Discord at go.chess.com forward
slash Discord then head over to
go.chess.com forward slash connect and
connect your account and you're done you
can now compete in the weekly arena for
our Discord community and win free
Diamond membership use x-clamp Discord
in chat now and we'll be back soon but
don't go anywhere Magnus Carlson has
given a confession in English so more on
that right after the break
all right
chess.com's game review recently got a
major update here are four key notes at
the end of each game review you will now
see a summary of the game from your
coach your performance rating for that
game and a quick grade for you and your
opponent in the opening middle game and
end game we've added a new
classification called Miss for when a
move fails to take advantage of an
opportunity but it is otherwise a sound
move we've also changed the definition
of blunder now a move will only be
considered a blunder if it loses
material or allows a Checkmate coach
will now draw arrows and highlight
squares when you hover over or click on
the highlighted words in the move
explanation this should make move
explanations easier to follow finally
coach's explanations will now reference
specific pieces and threads in
explanations making move explanations
much more intuitive the new game review
experience is available on dot com right
now
what's the best way to follow any chess
event from the Champions chess tour to
the candidates speed chess championship
title Tuesday feed a world championship
and so much more chess.com events has
all of the top chess tournaments played
both over the board and online
analyze and review games from the
world's greatest players with live
commentary cloud analysis opening
Explorer and table bases find all the
key event information including
schedules prizes results news reports
player bios tie breaks and more
even compete by voting for your
predicted results
explorechess.com events today on web or
with our IOS and Android apps and
experience chess like never before
[Music]
foreign
up we did promise you a confession from
Magnus in English and here he is he
asking the audience and us a very
sincere question
uh I'll do this one in English it's
something I'm like genuinely curious
about so I see that on the screen the
notation says Knight G to F6 I'm
genuinely curious why that is as Knight
dm6 is not legal I thought that you
should just write Knight of six without
the notation should just say Knight F6
so if any experts out there no I'll
certainly be curious to to learn what
the explanation is
there we see Magnus asking this question
or notation
um
David
you're uh your resident chess.com expert
is this a philosophical question is this
a technical question I don't even know
where to begin I must admit I would have
written Knight gf6 as well I think just
out of habit of course not df6 is an
illegal move in this position uh due to
a pin on this night but this is where
Magnus was pointing out he played the
move Knight to F6 is the only night that
can reach that and
Judah what would you have done which
side are you on this is uh yeah
important Live question right now
guys with the face expression Magnus was
giving this question and I was kind of
shocked with with the topic he brought
up in the opening I understand that he
does not have any problem in that stage
of the opening and he had plenty of time
to share this uh question with the
audience but still I was surprised I
think I would write Knight F6
we need your vote uh-huh well Knight F6
is correct but however
it depends how sharp I was so if I was
an autopilot I would write Knight gf6
absolutely and if I was sharp and say
df6 is not possible what a diplomatic
answer
no I'm just saying it it depends on my
intelligence levels on that day
but I I actually I think probably it
would slide on the autopilot Knight gf6
but Knight F6 is correct I mean like a
Comfort Dental says the NG F6 theorem of
life but okay I want to also ask the
question is this a worrying sign that
Magnus is concerning himself with little
detail or is this just good news because
Magnus is in a great mood and obviously
when you're in a great mood you play
great chess
I don't know I think for him it was kind
of funny that a very unexpected thought
to share and he wanted to make everybody
laugh or being curious
he does have a curious mind he loves the
stats uh that's why he's obsessed with a
lot of sports often we'll be out at a
bar and he's just like oh by the way did
you see this thing and it's often just a
kind of a word pun or something in the
news that amused him and it's it's yeah
I don't know how structured uh how
structured his brain is but these things
they are important and it does make
great content and do you agree he's
trolling people
I think it's a mix he's genuinely
interested in the answers
but you know it's funny that the people
are using the confessional boost for
different purposes right I mean most of
the players are not very active on that
for example Hikaru is just taking it as
part of his job and he's happy to share
his views on on every position it's very
interesting how players are sharing
their thoughts someone who I'm surprised
hasn't been using the confessional at
all is Anish giri
Anish Gary is known for his banter he's
known to share with us his thoughts
quote openly
and this not this tournament at all yeah
I think uh especially after winning the
Tata steel Masters earlier this year
he's realized that full Focus does bring
results this year during that event he
was barely tweeting at least by his
standards and it seemed to pay off but
uh yeah I'm not sure which players have
the most sins to confess uh I think that
was I mean that's the beauty of having
these confessional boxes we just see
players just getting stuff off their
chest relevant irrelevant it doesn't
matter if it's just a peek inside their
mind and notation is hard actually uh
yeah my one of my first coaches said to
the re kind of the moment he realized I
kind of had a decent talent for chess
was when on a score sheet I wrote down
without him explaining that I needed to
Rook dd2 because that type of thing is
hard and it's not the robot in Star Wars
Rook R2D2 it's rook dd2 and uh yeah
these things I think it took me a few
years to pick up but
apparently even the top players struggle
with notation sometimes yeah but it's
interesting that when I was a kid let's
say when was it 86 I was 10 years old
and many times when I was traveling
together with my sisters playing in
tournaments together and then of course
we were like chatting and to think all
the time with each other and during the
game we were playing the game we made
the move and then we were in big opens
and stuff like that and we were walking
around and chatting about people we were
not chatting about Chess we were just
chatty like talking here but then at one
point people were complaining when I
played together with Sophia and 86 and
under 14 years Championship that was the
first time that they were telling no no
no no no no tops during the game so by
the time we played in 88 at the Olympia
that was very clear that we cannot talk
we cannot chat with each other so that
was the cut down for me that no chance
during the the game but later on I was
witnessing and I knew that there's a lot
of players who are chatting with each
other you know and even many times I I
heard that a lot of the guys they go to
the bathroom and there they talk yes
that's true
and it's not legal yeah I've had a lot
of business decisions decisions are made
in the male bathrooms but you know I I
was from a very interesting generation
because at schools we learned
descriptive notation so it was like Pawn
to King four porn to King five I don't
know why we learned it no idea but it
was at the high level they were all
using algebraic by that time so it just
felt like Grand Master notation
algebraic
Kitty stuff
back to the old days there were books
very nice beautiful books where they
were writing King Knight three and then
I still have at home this in the old
times they had these chess sets where
the knights have a mark on it a king ah
you know so when the king knight from G1
goes to B5 to the queen side it's still
the king Knight so it's just full
confusion it's like Queen's Rook to
King's Bishop one it's like yeah it's
great but I tell you something for
beginners it's actually a great great
notation and anyhow enough about the
olden days
let's get started back to the bird's eye
view and we haven't taken a look at the
game between chakra and mamajarov and
Wesley so and remember
Shaq yesterday propelled himself up the
standings by beating Fabiana caruana he
went from I think Ninth Place all the
way to fourth place
yeah and uh early days in this one I
think uh let's do an action replay of
how we got to this position it's now
move 16 uh the players have played
relatively quickly and uh it started off
with the Queen's Gambit accepted D takes
C4 this has happened in a few of Shaq's
games so far we saw him uh have this
draw earlier in the event against Abdul
satorov in this brunch of the Queen's
camper accepted E4 played the most
ambitious move met by a Counter-Strike
E5 Knight out to F3 a check blocked by
the White Knight and here Knight to D7
uh from Wesley so I think we saw a
different move from abdusator of earlier
in the event and here we saw both sides
castling very standard stuff but I think
the first big decision was Bishop takes
C3 white was threatening to jump forward
with the Knight of a very kind of
typical idea utilizing this pin on the
Black Knight on F6 so black party with
the bishop pair and she kicked back the
White Knight and it was around here in
the break due that you were saying
White's position looks beautiful
yes because at this point I was really
happy for White having the G5 Bishop
giving the PIN to the f69 with the plan
of Knight E3 and centralized the Knight
eventually to the E5 also the queen from
E1 can show up on G3 to activate
and also time to time of course F4 and
E5 was in there yeah definitely like the
good old days
F4 E5 lots of uh openings have been won
that way
I agree with you Judah I love wise
position as well as having the bishop
pair you have all the potential
yeah however after H6 maybe a big
decision controversial decision here he
simply captured on F6 Shaq rather than
preserve the bishop pair and I think if
Bishop H4 then probably Black's plan was
to play Knight G6 and somehow chasing
the bishop either to exchange on F6 or
if divide Square Bishop Bishop moves
then Knight H5 also possible so for
example if you keep the Bishops on the
board suddenly the Black Knights come in
maybe the bishop will be eliminated
anyway okay Shaq decided uh he will go
for this trade on his own terms he took
on F6 Queen takes F6 the White Knight
threatened to jump into E3 and we have a
couple more moves just played This
Moment Knight D3 jumping in with the
Black Knight and it has been captured
and Wesley so is away from the board we
will see the black Rook take on D3 and
after rotates D3 the big question is
what's happening after Knight to D5
hitting the black queen
and it's right there okay Wesley's back
at the board and this move is instantly
played by Shaq yeah I'm guessing that uh
black is very much putting their hopes
on the Move C5 C4 to save The Rook
obviously you have to move the queen
that didn't Escape my attention but
I mean I was worried for the blackrock's
life for example just this Pawn to C4
push yeah exactly then C4 comes and then
Black's whole rationale they said the
night is supported by just one Pawn so
it can be destabilized with Bishop E6
but probably Rook D1 seems to be quite
powerful
and still Black's problems have not gone
away
yeah I guess black might give a check at
some point uh just push your king into
the corner a trade and a position like
this one how would we start to evaluate
Bishop to E6 this is very logical the
all these moves very natural okay he
actually went Queen back to d8 so we
might see something slightly different
but similar to this
yeah it's not clear how white can
improve his position because black is
very active and later on he will be able
to push his spawns B5 A5 B4
so white also has to be
alert on this yeah and uh should we see
how Queen D it has affected the game
instead of uh Queen to D6 Black's Queen
simply went back
so yeah again one of the most natural
moves would be to try to hit harass this
Rook
maybe Knight F4 might be something to
consider
hitting the piece and I'm not sure where
to go
can I go in
you want to go to Just
feels a bit shaky but a rook on the
second rank Rook on the seventh rank
earlier my notation story was about Rook
D2 so I'll put the Rook on D2
question is what happens if Rook D1
and an end game windy one let's say if
you exchange then you don't have a good
place for your Bishop yeah open file
looks very strong for white
yeah despite the evaluation bar not
being too impressed it does feel like
white is the one having the fun right uh
in the game yeah because Bishop B6 then
Knight takes Android D7 and that's
yeah that final position was very strong
for white
so yeah Knight F4 looks like a nice way
to kind of force this Rook to make a
decision other moves would include maybe
C4 or queen E2
after C4 my worries would be for a while
that Rook on D4 will be quite stable or
at least the black Rook will not get in
trouble the only thing is that white
will exchange The Rook playing Rook D1
for example a line like this one or to
D1
oh sorry my mouse slip there Rook to D1
yeah if we can trade off this Rook then
it feels like white has the advantage
with this beautiful fortified Knight
but it has a more pleasant game that's
true yeah is it enough that's the
question because it makes a huge
difference this setup having the white
Pawn on C4 stabilizing the Knight on D5
and the black pawn is still on C5
contrary to the line we just looked at
before when Black Bomb was on C4 Queen
on C5 it was much more active position
and also the D5 Knight wouldn't be so
secured
now it's easier to kick back this piece
later in the game
so uh yeah Shaq looks like a successful
opening
a little white at least no risk small
Advantage Maybe
strategically
well at Wesley so be unhappy here
because it does feel like a position
where Wesley is just playing for two
results
a draw and a loss
yeah Wesley he's quite pragmatic he
knows he's solid enough he should be
fine with best play but
yeah I would be more worried if I were
him right now
I don't know I would never be happy in a
position like this where it's kind of
draw at best if the opponent doesn't
find anything to
um too ambitious
how about you Judith
well I would rather play it from the
right side that's clear and I'm also
hesitating and thinking what happens if
let's say why it goes Queen E2 and go
into this some concrete ideas after C4
to go then Knight F4
okay sacrifice upon for initiative yeah
let's jump in there and uh this is very
ambitious and also very forcing you
mentioned Queen's E2 hitting this Rook
C4 Force Knight F4 okay so I'll take up
your challenge I know Ivanka would take
the spawn
using
[Laughter]
I f it doesn't matter the reply is
always going to be the same Queen will
come to B6 check back and I might
announce it as well no I won't after
King H1 you just simply go we should be
six that's yeah exactly how I would play
it just before I fork the two pieces on
D5 it should be six
yeah it looks solid enough for black as
long as this Rook doesn't get trapped
but it feels like you should have enough
Escape squares but we have we need two
C4 on the board okay probably white
wants to go Rook D1
it's a very shock type of move after
Queen E2 C4 okay I was gonna say to play
Knight F4 can't beat the pawn and be
ambitious but yeah this looks very
logical as well but this looks a better
way for uh for white than before because
Black Ink Queen was on D6 and we were
watching looking Queen C5 check and now
the queen on d8 is much more passive and
somehow it's in the way after Rook takes
D1 Rook takes D1 okay for the moment
there is no serious threat or white but
still somehow the queen is not active at
all and the C4 Pawn is under attack yeah
the C4 Pawn
it might mean that black has to trade
Rooks here and then play a move like B5
but that feels slow somehow The Black
Queen on d8 is a bit of a Target uh for
the white Rooks on D1
yeah it feels very shaky but I'm sure
Wesley has calculated this and
I like to play with white if let's say
Rook takes D1 Rook takes D1 you play B5
to protect the pawn let's put this on
the board and I'm wondering if white can
have such a plan like F4
wow and start to play F4 F5 so if Bishop
E6 for example I would come back with
the Knight to E3 and then push F5
very strong potentially Queen V6 for
example
I mean why is the evaluation bar not
reacting this looks beautiful for white
because it doesn't like me
it's a sleep today I guess black hash
has to play Bishop C8 only safe Square
yeah but maybe after in the next move
Bishop B7 is stronger I don't know
but in Blitz you just play this as white
you just kind of but this is not
Armageddon yet
otherwise E5 and you would think that
the game is well not over but it's very
close I mean you play like rookies
yeah unfortunately here I mean E5 would
be powerful if not Bishop takes F5
using the pen
Queen F3 you can just move the Rook yes
and this Knight will drop if the White
Queen takes the black Bishop
on a five so yeah sharp sharp stuff B5
this position is pretty much by force
and it just depends on
uh moves like F4 I'm also looking at E5
just to uh threaten Knight F6 check
tricks tricks I'd play it in Blitz
that's for sure but there's a a
guideline that I use when I go for
tricks is like if it's an improving move
and it threatens a trick I'm in there
I'm playing it if it's just a move that
might not be strategically great then I
would be very very cautious about
playing for tricks
well the thing is that E5 looks very
powerful because of the threat of Knight
F6 at the same time it gives up the
stability of the Knight on D5 so the
question is whether black and play
something in order to play for example
Queen f8 seems to be a nice move
I think and then it's easier to kick out
the Knight on D5 possibly yeah but you
still have I mean in this particular
situation there's still things like
Queen coming to E4
and then your idea due that I've not
given up on it of f4 F5
yeah a four or five maybe there's
something even stronger here
oh yeah maybe not 97 yeah 97 I thought
this was impossible due to a check
double attack but I could just move the
king Ah that's that's what I thought too
and the rook in the corner is hit or
maybe Rook D4 maybe a nice active block
here and yeah it's tempting okay to
stuff
but uh yeah the position could easily
Sprint to life it does feel like Shaq is
the one making things happen but Wesley
can he react is he solid enough
maybe he is just trading Rooks and B5
well it's also something that black
might be thinking of to give up the pawn
so let's say to play with black queen A5
or Bishop E6 doesn't matter let's say
Bishop E6 let's jump back in Bishop B6
yeah and after Rook takes these three
takes takes and to play Rook C8 or
another idea to go simply Queen A5
just the idea is to put pressure on this
Pawn long term yeah but still it's a
phone up right I mean you can go see
four stabilize and it's it's only for
two results yeah yeah
and uh well it looks like mamajarov has
the upper hand there but let's head back
to the bird's eye view because whilst
you guys were talking I saw that Magnus
had taken a rather spicy decision you
know it is like the modern approach to
chess when you have you don't know what
to do push the H Pawn and there we see
Magnus pushing H7 H5 can we head to that
game
yeah I think we should head to that game
uh this one has progressed Judy you
called it very early on white now has a
maroxy bind uh White to pawn structure
looks beautiful pawn and C4 Rock Solid
porno E4 F3 white soon or later we'll
play the move B3 and uh yeah set up this
structure this structure black needs to
do something to erode these Pawns
eventually if you want to fight for any
advantage or even fight for equality but
H5 what could the idea be here first of
all
think he just believes that he can
play H5 with the idea maybe at some
point H4 but only a much later stage
maybe he wants to go Knight H7 to open
up the diagonal but it's basically just
a strategic move I think that uh
you know these are exactly the positions
when you're maneuvering here and there
and you have to pay attention what is
changing in every move so you have to
stay alert that if there is going to be
something the your pinpoint the
opportunity now white has to make a
decision how to be playing uh this
position is he ready to go B4 and then
Knight B3 and be active on that side
that way or he wants to play simply B3
and make maneuvering or he wants to go
Queen to F2
it's a it's a maneuvering kind of
position and then black is thinking well
should I have my queen on C7 or it's
good on d8 is he going to be playing
Knight C5 or Knight E5 so maneuvering
starts right and I I was going to ask is
the culmination of White's plan
basically to put the Knight on D5
I've seen that done many times myself
I think after Knight D5 maybe black
wants to go
well not now but after Queen like the
whole point is like you build build
build yourself a home and then you know
once you've got got there Knight to D5
because these positions I find are very
complicated to play for black if white
just sits there has a picnic enjoys
their space
yes of course an id5 is over is an
alternative also here in this at this
point it's an alternative and black is
not going to be capturing on day5 for
sure either he would be playing Knight
H7 and kick over E6 with E6 the D5
Knight or he can also go E6 immediately
so Knight D5 is an option but I think if
white wants to play for Advantage he
should make some preparational moves
because what I'm thinking the reason I'm
asking all these questions is because
I'm Aryan you know he's had a very rough
time in the tournament he's only on two
points out of 15. he wants to for morale
get some kind something you know one
point isn't good enough so why not kind
of simplify sit on the space and then
kind of go for some simplification
maneuver yeah I guess uh as far as I
understand it Knight D5 is often a
useful idea but it's normally when you
force a concession out of black as
Judith says when you Force black to take
and maybe improve the white Pawn
structure white gets a nice strong Pawn
on D5 you can take either way uh or you
Force black to weaken the structure here
if you compare spaceways White's the one
with more space white has the center
white has these strong points on e4 C4
and normally when you have more space
your opponent's cramped you don't want
to trade pieces so I wouldn't rush but
like you say it's uh it's on the cards
and if it's not going anywhere then I
would build up first
um so yeah I mean the build up that's
the hard part and I've got to admit I'm
surprised the evaluation Bar says plus
one for white such a big Advantage when
it's just a looks like a slow
maneuvering game so for me that's the
most confusing part about this position
of course Ariane has to pick a plan and
uh follow it through it's a very
interesting because we've been looking
at this position from aryan's side but
of course Magnus really isn't a must win
situation and prior to the game Sarah
our reporter caught up with Magnus
whilst Magnus was in a hurry to get to
his game and Magnus talked about his
chances in the tournament
s
um
for example turtle
well thank you um
foreign
[Laughter]
taking a tumble there at Magnus saying
that he's out of time he needs to start
winning but overall he feels that his
play is more than okay
yeah he's got to be hoping it's not him
who Takes a Tumble in this round I mean
magnus's play Judah you mentioned
there's been a few moments maybe lacking
the Killer Instinct or misevaluating
things uh that's very kind of
uncharacteristic of him it feels like
something isn't quite right but he's not
playing badly I mean uh let's forget the
first round where he was clearly out of
shape against uh Carolina some strange
uh blunders there but ever since then
it's not as if he's playing badly it's
just not kind of at his usual High kind
of uh his high standards where he's
blowing people off the board so it's
difficult in tournaments like this right
if you're not in the flow to string
together those wins well absolutely and
uh I mean that's also a fact that
whoever plays with Magnus they know that
he's number one he's the best player in
the world right now and of course
everybody puts all the preparation and
the mindset is very clear against him
right that you don't want to lose you
want to make a great fight you know that
he can turn out things in any position
so everybody is is very alert when when
they are playing against him so it's
also not so easy to create for him these
winning chances and and create these
opportunities
what he feels he feels that he may run
out of time and probably this is the
moment this is the game where if he's
not winning today in classical
it is getting really small chance that
he is going to be the winner of the
event because this should be one of the
the day where I mean he's a better
player Tara is in a very difficult
position in the tournament at the same
time he knows it exactly that no matter
who is the underdog in the tournament it
happened before that Tori had a
difficult tournament and won against
Magnus because of course it happens with
players who are doing very badly in a
tournament or their Underdog things are
going very badly but still against the
best player or against the leader they
score a point yeah and uh well Magnus
does need to win and he does leave the
board I mean but is this position the
right type of position to outplay
someone from
it's going to be difficult because white
is so Rock Solid especially if Arya
decides to do nothing if white just
plays a move like B3 and just sits it's
going to be hard for Magnus but then
again all the pieces are on the board
it's going to be maximum tension maybe
time pressure will play A Part later
Ariane after 15 moves has spent 40
minutes already
um so I think Magnus is going to play
the Mind Games just as much as the board
and I do remember actually two years ago
uh Judah we were commentating together
in Magnus I think he'd struggled in the
past first half of Norway chess and he
put together what was it four or five
wins in a row at the end and one of
those wins was as black against Ariane
grinding down a long long game where it
looked like it would be a draw for a
while so
it's possible he's got history he's got
a track record I think it's it's not a
bad kind of position to to play on of
course it's very difficult if white
decides really not to do anything but
it's also not so easy not to do anything
I mean you have to make a move
so if you have your optimally placed
pieces and you can see that the pieces
are just very much standing on their
places which this kind of position
demands but still you have to come up
with a plan and once you're going to be
making a plan pushing your pawns for
example B3 or B4 then after B4 already
immediately Knight E5 can come and there
is a question what's going on with the
C4 phone or if you go A4 then maybe
Knight C5 so the B3 Square can be
vulnerable of course it's a very
balanced game and I think I would pick
white because it's just more more space
in the position at the same time of
course if you start playing for
improving your position you may do
weaknesses some things can show up it
can get concrete maybe in a good moment
there are many positions like this when
Rook C5 may also come though after H5
maybe it's not so good but maybe Rook C5
H4 Rook H5 G5 I don't know there are
some creative plans which can come up or
or just play Knight H7 E6 Knight H7 G5
maybe regrouping the Knight to E5 G6
uh maybe I'm exaggerating but sometimes
this G5 Bishop B5 plan can be an
interesting plant but of course black
very much has to look at what white is
doing
yeah absolutely definitely black needs
to reacts to what's plan and yeah
definitely interesting position I think
should we take a pause from this game
and revisit the other games
yeah there's a lot of action happening
elsewhere
um I think the two games that have maybe
just progressed the fastest and the most
are the clashes between gokash and Guru
and also between uh farusha and Nakamura
where to go first can we go to the
battle uh between farugia and Hikaru
because I I like this battle primarily
because it feels like they're jostling
for who is going to be ranked number two
in the world
you know will they play it safe with the
classical ratings or are they gonna take
it as a matter of Pride and try to blast
the other one from the board
to make a great pair oh very good this
is a key we game for the tournament
standings I've been booking up on my
puns in the brick but uh yeah for Asian
meanwhile he's covered up his fruity
shirt gutted but yeah this game really
tense Judith what do you make of the
developments here it's been a few moves
since we left it
the pawn structure is typical for black
I believe having been born on c6d5 in
these structures and F6 is very common
so the Knight is not in danger with all
kind of queen C1 move so it's ready to
move and jump to F7 or exchanging the
pawns on e4 and then Knight comes to F5
but for the moment I think the pawn on
D5 stands very good because it keeps the
A3
pretty badly plays Knight so it cannot
come to C4 this is very important for
the moment because that's the only piece
which is not doing very well in White's
position because for example if it would
be on A4 that would be a completely
whole different story because then white
would have a clear Advantage so just by
having the Knight on A3 this gives black
a lot of opportunities and for the
moment the C5 weakness and the C6 it's
not so disturbing
yeah and uh Hikaru away from the board
our fourth commentator does that mean he
might be in the confessional Booth I
can't wait if he does reveal his
thoughts we will go straight to him on
site as soon as he has a report ready
for us
[Laughter]
[Music]
I think it's quite I've never been in
this position before where one of the
players are given the inside knowledge
and not only that but they're actually
commentating on the other games as well
Long Live Hikaru that's all I can say no
less than world number two as long as he
avoids defeat in this game and if
Carolina doesn't win uh yeah if I Cara
wins this game he's going to cement that
spot as well number two yeah that side
hustle of being an on-site reporter I
think he's got a future there somewhere
but uh meanwhile farrugio has been in
the tank for a long time so I wouldn't
be surprised if Hikaru is uh kind of
unloading all his thoughts there uh
farusha spent almost an hour and we've
only had 13 moves this is only move 13
actually right now
yeah Judah I'm looking at what this
position I'm just thinking what is the
Knight doing on A3 he was the one who
put it there it feels like hikaru's got
a healthy position
uh White's done nothing wrong so White's
probably not worse but it feels like hey
Cara is going to be very happy well I
think white should be playing something
with an idea that the black is provoked
to exchange the pawns on e4 which is not
so easy to force black to do so but of
course for example Queen C2 looks uh
very sensible move but at the same time
maybe D takes E4 would come after that
because Queen cannot take on e4 Queen B2
might be a move I don't know if we can
give that up but somehow of course Queen
to C1 or C2 would be a very sensible
move and somehow to take the opportunity
with the Knight to probably regrouping
but I don't know if white will have the
time for it to go let's say queen is C1
Knight D7 and let's go Knight B1 and
Knight C3 I know it looks awful and slow
but I just have to recover with my
knight from A3 somehow now let's put
this on the board Knight to F7 would
likely happen after Queen C1 and the
White Knight you want one move two moves
three moves and we reach the promised
land of C5 but it takes so long that's
the issue three moves looks alive
yeah it doesn't quite feel like yeah the
problem is that probably black takes on
e4 and then C5 is possible to play and
then black is just much better yeah
if this opens up this position if the
center gets exploded then Black's
Bishops might come to life especially
this light squared Bishop later on but
this is a problem for a wife exactly and
this could be exactly what Hikaru is
planning and on the subject of hikaru's
thoughts get this we have a four and a
half minute confessional from Hikaru
which we will play during the break so
if the twitch audience want to see it
you'll have to make sure that you
subscribe
there you go
can't wait I can't wait to hear his
thoughts what do you think he has in
store for us four and a half minutes
he's going to be breaking down all of
the games I think so oh is he's gonna
give us a full-on confessional about how
he got in his preparation how this has
been done before what do you think I
want to hear what he thinks of
farrugia's choice of shirt
the very nice shirt that he's wearing
[Laughter]
Curry
he's full of surprises and in this
position I think he's feeling very
comfortable evaluation bar roughly in
the center but that does maybe uh
deceive us it feels like black is
hitting this Pawn black has ideas he
mentioned it actually drew it already
already uh kind of in this position D
takes E4 and C5 directly uh just how
does white react it's not so easy and uh
I think for a human it's so easy to go
wrong pick the wrong plan kind of place
slightly too slowly when maneuvering re
kind of centralizing this Knight and
yeah I must say I prefer black slightly
but I also believe if we have Nakamura
giving a confessional boost a few
minutes of coverage it means also that
he feels very comfortable in the
position he is in and the
probably that's also the reason we can
hear that actually he takes E4 and C5 is
already a threat at this point not only
Queen to take taking on B2 so white has
to be careful a lot even it came to my
mind that maybe white will have to take
on H6 and play Queen C2 but it's hard to
imagine that the
that would be the best move for white
well let's not keep everyone in suspense
and so let's actually take a break and
remember you have to be a subscriber on
Twitch to listen to hikaru's thoughts
so take it away Hikaru
welcome back everyone so so we're here
once again today is round number six of
Norway chess um so as always I'll start
with the other games before I talk about
my own so magnus's game is kind of
interesting Magnus is starting to play
Sicilian obviously was here in the
confessional box um before me he's
playing the Sicilian I mean Atari plays
Bishop B5 instead of sort of going into
the open Society now all those look kind
of normal but I'm a little surprised
that tari did not play Queen takes D4
and general Queen D4 is much more
principled leads to a much more set kind
of position with very clear-cut plans
for both size generally after Queen E4
block we'll play some E5 with Knight F6
or H6 first in that order um and it's
much more Concrete in fact I think
Magnus might have played this against
vicious with the white piece or
something very similar so Atari playing
Knight takes D4 is a little bit
surprising I think the tari basically
here is saying that he's going to be
aggressive he wants to play like rookie
one Knight C3 Bishop G5 maybe Queen D2
something along these lines at least so
it's a little bit it seems like tari
wants a game as opposed to trying to be
solid here so again I think Magnus is
probably going to get very good chances
to win today so that's the first game
goo catch versus Anish is a typical slob
who played a gazillion times I mean I
feel like I've even I want to say I've
seen on each plays from both colors as
far back as like 2014 2013 ages ago at
any rate
um so not very exciting in that game
um I expect that to actually be drawn
pretty quickly just to be clear because
it's unless Google cash has some great
idea it would appear the good cash is
the one who's been surprised by Anish
and I'm assuming it's going to simplify
so that's two games then there is of
course the game between Wesley and Shaq
that just looks like a standard Queen's
gamb accepted maybe small Advantage for
white with the central punching from f2d
or not F2 sorry G2 to E4
um but you know fairly balanced I would
say and that leaves us with the other
game which is the game between Notre
pack and Fabiano where of course you
know we have the classic um classic Duel
of like the ex-lovers as we like to say
Obviously um I don't literally mean that
in the true sense but you have of course
Fabiano who work with russom cast and
genre for many many years
um even through the candidates I think
in 20 the 2020 or 2019 2020 around then
of course they split after that they
haven't worked together now Roost Thomas
here with Notre Beck Abby star of the
very talented Who's Becky Jr of course
what's also funny about this game is
that I was wearing this exact same shirt
and it was in the first round of the
candidates last uh I think it was late
June if I remember correctly when
Fabiano played the same Knight B3 idea
with to go Knight A5 against me so it's
kind of funny to see this line on the
board Fabian with the black piece in
this situation where it's against me he
had the white pieces um so that looks I
mean it's pretty normal so far I think
we'll see which line Fabiano goes for
again I've looked at this quite a bit so
I won't reveal any of the specific lines
but there are there are multiple options
here for black that should be playable
so we'll see what Fabiano does um I
don't expect him to be that surprised by
the choice though because of course he
played this against me with the white
pieces and one thing that Fabian is very
good at is memorization on top of all
the great prep he has because
memorization tends to be very good so
even if he hasn't looked at it recently
he definitely has looked it from the
white side so I expect him to play
pretty quickly and we'll see how that
develops and then that takes us of
course to the last game which is my game
against alireza where once again up
until the last two moves we're following
my game against unleash in round number
four I think it was because this is the
sixth round so uh Ali Reza played Knight
A3 in this position in this this
position a little a little bit unusual
but of course something I looked at a
couple days ago and so I played 96 and
now it appears in Ollie Rose is deep in
the tank now as far as this game itself
goes it's a simple one-off and of course
anything can happen I'm feeling pretty
good though because it appears that I've
out prepped alireza um I don't know if
he simply hasn't looked at 96 or what's
going on but I would say that looking at
the overall term and just in general at
Ali Reza's future I would say the one
weakness that I've noticed in this
tournament in particular is that he
seems to not be super well prepared it
seems like if he gets surprised like
against Fabiano his reaction wasn't very
good in that game and and I don't know
but it just feels like the prep isn't
quite as good as it was going into the
candidates so that's the one pro thing I
would say um but again this this is a
one-off game anything can happen but
that is the one critique I would have is
that it feels like his preparation it
isn't quite as good as some of the other
players like Fabiano very specifically
so he probably needs to work on that a
little bit as far as the game goes of
course we'll see what Ali Rosen wants to
do here there are many options he can
play for C3 D4 you can play D3 you can
go Knight C4 uh maybe even E5 as well so
we'll just have to wait and see what
happens but I'm already up 15 minutes on
the clock assuming that he didn't move
as soon as I came in here um and I'm
feeling pretty good so we'll just see
how the game develops
foreign
thank you to Hikaru and incidentally
there is a part two coming up in the
next break and Hikaru there giving us a
lot of his thoughts a lot of suggestions
predictions I mean what did you guys
make of it
for me it was very interesting what he
said that gokish Anish game it will be
simplified it's a draw yeah uh
I I liked his his coaching tips for his
opponent where he said well you might
need to work on this part of the game
but he also said it that he out out
prepared alireza right he was preparing
on this Knight A3 so he knew what might
be standing on the board and with Knight
H6 he was happy
yeah interesting stuff and uh what do we
think of all of his evaluations was he
downplaying the excitement on some of
the boards
or just spot on as usual I'll report it
well we can actually test his evaluation
of the good cash and ichigiri game
because he said well trades trades will
happen it's going to be a quick draw
is he right
yeah big question I mean I trust a car
more than I trust myself but uh I'm
hoping for some excitement maybe he kind
of saw it into the future and uh spotted
that this type of thing Could Happen
White's last move E4 trying to get the
Queens off Anish actually interestingly
gave up a pawn just a few moves ago Dude
it should we backtrack and see what
happened let's see how all this happened
yeah so we were slightly confused by
kokesh's choices earlier in the game but
it looks like they've been Justified
this is the current position let's go
back F4 was where we left it uh we
thought okay we agree with the
computer's assessment here question mark
for this move giving black uh tempo for
free seemingly Knight to C4 very useful
uh the white Bishop dropped back to see
what uh to E1 and after a capture Queen
to F3 was the idea from gokash hitting
the Rook now utilizing the vacated F3
square and he's gonna simply capture
this Knight next move and each Castle
free understandably and this was where
kakash he'd calculated he could win a
porn Knight to E4 this Pawn is falling
off the board and he said okay take it
Retreat and uh this was the position
where white gave a check
uh sorry black ever check even white
blocked with Rook C2 very nice move
actually maybe the only move to stay in
the game and after Rook C8 E4 to take
Queens to take Queens off in this
direction this was a really necessary
move because black had a huge attack
against the white king just a few times
ago without E4 I think this would have
been deadly the pin here the pin here
but anyway for initiative to keep the
pressure
well the question is whether can uh
Anish avoid the queen exchange this is
the big question I believe he might be
thinking on what way to capture the pawn
because we need four of course that's
the most obvious move at the same time I
would also consider I think maybe this
is what Anish is thinking of to go Rook
fd8 possibly
because if white would be taking on
these three Rook D3 then still the E4
Pawn is under attack and Rook D1 is
something to watch after for white but
maybe it's it's not really possible I I
have to think also whether
really this Rook date idea can work
yeah should we jump in and show some
lines because big decision if a niche
can't keep the Queens on we're headed
for an end game uh let's just show if
yeah the most obvious move could we take
C4 we'll likely reach this end game
where white actually has a two versus
one majority on the queen side so long
term white has some chances there
perhaps but black is sufficiently active
should be level which color would you
take David I would take good question
Instinct wise white I'll play a move
like Bishop A5 and I'll say okay I'll
just slowly unravel the Knight on e4 is
superb
I often over kind of overestimate the
long term factors for the short term and
yeah short term as you say shoot it this
night it's beautiful
probably it's level I don't know exactly
because I love the Knight on e4 at the
same time the Knight on C4 is also uh
perfectly placed Knight right I think
the question is whether can black go G5
fast let's say Bishop A5 you want to
stop Rogue d8 right and after that I
would be thinking to go G5
so after rookie one or something I would
be play F5
and start being active with black
yeah suddenly you've created some
passports these guys could start running
actually maybe even quicker than uh
White's queen size majority
um yeah looking maybe okay for a niche
but whether it's more than okay that's a
big question to go back to the current
position you also mentioned this idea of
d8 and my question would be are you
winning the pawn back if I take Rooks
off the board and a bit of a passive
ugly move but Knight to D2
just to hold this Pawn
Ivanka do you like to keep the phones
also or he only take them take but I'm
gonna keep them this one I'm very
protective of because that Knight on e4
was too good
um I think 92 is a great move because
the great thing about White's position
is you can unravel as David's
highlighted yeah that being said after a
move like Rook to d8 I'm a bit tied up
as white to this night it's like the
glue but uh yeah will it still hold
things together after Bishop B4 incoming
Rook E3 maybe to E2 incoming well
probably white might have to play E5
which is not necessarily so tempting
because Knight D5 and then Knight B4
Knight E3 F4 is hanging as well so that
it's not easy not easy it can be
difficult
to make him a for white also with the
bishop and E1 defending the Knight on D2
it's not simple
yeah so maybe this is what Anish is
weighing up in his head he's kind of
coming to terms in the current position
with the queen trade but he has a very
interesting pose calculating variations
at the board oh wow an issue on the
camera
yeah he's like he said calculating for
sure it's like the battle he's passed
out fallen asleep someone should wake
him up
it's uh no I'm pretty sure he's
calculating I've seen him actually in
this post before when he's deep in the
tank well that suggests to me that he's
actually not calculating Queen takes
Pawn he's looking for alternatives
calculating something and
these two have some history because they
played each other in tata steel and uh
in that particular game Anish had the
white pieces and played a fantastic game
you know absolutely wiped the floor
against kukesh and
well these kind of like track history
with this term match history does it
have an impact on how a niche is feeling
whether he will take those chances
possibly like you said Ivanka I think he
won that game in what was it 18 20 moves
just beautiful double night sacrifice
checkmating attack and uh often if you
crush someone even if they're
world-class Grandmaster if you crush
someone you believe okay they're my
client now I'm gonna rack up the points
against them and it can be frustrating
you know I don't have an idea can't
black consider Queen takes C2
giving up a queen Judith yeah and uh he
doesn't give me time to discover
he was just toying with us
without takes born on the board after
some meditation there from Anish I think
we have to investigate Judith was this
an opportunity to yeah
let's jump in instead of Queen takes
Pawn if black had instead taken the Rook
and this would have been a check King
takes Queen Rook takes Knight I guess
just white block or does white runaway
let's say I run away from the check
the idea is to swing The Rook take the
pawn I just wanted to take the phone on
e4 and to have compensation somehow
yeah if you get two or three more moves
if you get a rook to d8 or C8 Bishop to
F6 it looks scary to start with before
Knight E4 Rook C8 let's say I move my
Bishop
let's say I use A5 again I don't know
why I'm attracted to that square and I
take C4 yeah probably it's not enough
but sometimes it
yeah if you get Bishop F6 we're coming
down stabilize the pieces of course I
wouldn't mind to have an extra Pawn on
B5 let's say
while you're at it opponent D5 would be
beautiful that's too nice to ask
interesting and not necessarily bad but
I guess Anish just felt it was too high
risk and uh instead let's go back to the
game we saw after E4 Queen takes E4
instead uh taking and this end game that
we discussed
yeah I mentioned that I would maybe take
white how about the two of you
you mentioned some ideas for black
Judith I think I wouldn't mind taking
black I like this G5 idea to create a
password on E-Pass spawn
I think the bishop on E1 is not standing
really well if it would be standing on
E3 it would be better yeah I have to say
I'm agreement with Judith it's the
bishop only one that is the problem
piece and it's gonna take too long to
mobilize it and also why it's Queen side
Pawns they're just so far back for them
to be effective whereas it's much easier
for black to advance their Pawns
yeah I think I instinctively said white
because I'm imagining a position with
all the Rooks off the board and white
spawns running but of course that's a
million miles away at this point
and actually white is somehow missing
one tempo I think from kind of Advantage
like Rook D1 Rook C1 would be a good
jump uh over the bishop but somehow it's
it's not exactly what the rules are
allowing
yeah if we could just channel it's in a
horse there and just jump over the
bishop that would be ideal but
yeah difficult actually again despite
the uh evaluation bar saying it's dead
level this is misleading it's still all
to play for your move is on the board
David yeah that Bishop was in the way of
The Rook jump so I think a natural
retort there from kakash and we're
expecting a move such as G5 for black
just why not trade off a double Pawn for
a healthy Pawn create a king-site
majority make sense but there is another
question for example that not only G5 is
an option for black but also Rook C6 or
yeah Rook C6 is something I would
consider trying to double The Rook on
the C5
yeah that being said white will just
play B3 eventually defend the Knight
I like your first plan I think P5 go for
it yeah immediate activity immediate
counter play and uh this one is going to
be a long end game grind who's gonna out
yeah the better player will win here
it's uh about who outplays the other
simply yeah
and uh well this one is looking to be
quite exciting strategic battle can we
go to the bird's eye view because I have
my eyes on Abdul sotorov against caruana
and I found it fascinating that Hikaru
mentioned that he was wearing the same
shirt I mean how does he remember these
things when Fabiano
um played Knight B3 himself
on the white side of that particular
variation in the candidates right yeah I
mean it needed Hikaru to prompt me there
to even record that game to remember
what shirt he wore like maybe he has a
special shirt against Fabio you think so
a lucky shirt
it's easy to remember
sometimes you know traveling to chess
tournaments you want to bring books you
want to bring a laptop you want to bring
everything why pack shirts you know and
uh here okay grammar brings up an
interesting point and says I hope Fabi
gets revenge for the chess kid cop lost
in order back and I you commentated on
that encounter but for what I read the
reports and I saw the show it seemed
like Fabi was getting great positions
against Nordic it was just an issue of
handling the complexities and the later
stages of the game yeah you're right
Ivanka these two have a lot of recent
history and uh in the chess kid cup they
actually had two matches against against
each other eight games in total uh
notabeck won both of those mini matches
two and a half one and a half but it was
close they were Landing blows on each
other and like you say out of the
opening it was always or nearly always
Fabby uh with the advantage but when the
clock's ticked when yeah kind of chaos
ensued and broke out when he lost
control Fabi uh things turned very very
quickly and uh kind of harshly against
him so I don't think either player will
read too much into that match it was
extremely close small margins and it was
rapid but that could be relevant if this
game goes to Armageddon if this Clash
gets decided there later I think
nordebec will have the upper hand
psychologically but uh meanwhile this
classical game Judith it's changed
slightly whites just made a big decision
it's very interesting position it is
just so fun to see the spawn structure
Having Eight pawns lined up both sides
because it straightened out yeah after
Knight takes D6 and C takes D6 was the
last move and it is really interesting
to see what kind of plans the players
have in mind and the big question is for
me whether white is going to be playing
the for now or later stage or he wants
to be let's say playing A5 and the A4 A5
for example trying to put a little
pressure on the queen side
yeah it feels like white needs to open
things at some point before black gets
full control I'm not sure where the
black King's good to hide to be honest
maybe it'll just hide over here on G7 uh
you can make an argument for sitting in
the center but yeah if black gets one or
two more moves if black gets like H4 uh
maybe a D5 himself
even C5 sometimes then uh yeah it feels
like Fabi should be happy what would you
go for you mentioned two ideas Judith I
don't think anything on the king side is
one of these two right on the king side
I don't want to do anything with white
ever I'm just sitting and waiting and
wait black to decide whether he's
playing h4g4 Knight F4 or whatever I
think I would uh I don't know if if D4
oh but then you know we wouldn't be
following the rules that have been
written since time immoral immemorial
which was like your opponent works on
the wings you strike out in the center
well you know bringing it back to basics
yes it's good wisdom though it's a it's
an idiom for a reason and D4 was the
first moves across my mind it's just
about whether I guess he finesses it
first with some Maneuvers like do you
prepare it with Rook D1 do you kind of
throw A4 A5 in first and then kind of
wait for later with uh with D4
some questions to ask well there are a
lot of questions let's say A4 black
cannot go well even A5 is possible by
the way because the A6 B6 maybe cannot
be taken but maybe it can because Asic
A5 phone will be also under attack so
after A4
let's jump in and show these lines A4
yeah A4 maybe an unpleasant move because
black is just missing to go to G7
immediately right and after A5 to go to
V8 or something C5
yeah I guess you don't really want to
play a move like B5 white might lock
down uh this Pawn is an eternal Target
later in the game
maybe I say maybe because that pawn
might drop off for white as well on A6
it's also a question whether
should black go Knight F4 and A4 we see
on the board oh wow okay this is the
game position A4 confirmed you mentioned
Knight F4 Judith just to act as a
distraction
yeah
I mean I think it makes sense to to go
Knight F4 also H4 is something
immediately H4 and H3 surely to block it
up
uh for not to back here yeah but the H4
was played I believe that all these kind
of Knight G3 will
it's eliminated from now on
but do you need to touch those King side
pawns because once you do then a knight
can put itself on F4 for the rest of all
time and there's no way that white can
do anything about it
meanwhile
black yeah can get a pawn to H3 but you
know if you can meet that with G3 is it
such a problem
yeah good question I mean visually I
would love to play a move like H3 for
black just because the white king will
be kind of exposed slightly on the light
squares but first of all is their time
that's the question why is now
threatening a takes B6 so maybe there's
no time for H3 and secondly as you say
Ivanka maybe if you can't open things up
for black on the king side then
yeah it's not clear whether that's
actually a gain or not it's very
committal
um the White Knight given the G3 Square
as well if black ever pushes with H3
such strategic decisions here on every
turn it's
yeah small decisions we'll decide this
game
A5 first how to react it's B5 forced
Rook B8 feels
odd somehow to give white to the a file
I for the gold B5 yeah me too yeah it's
interesting because you guys were
discussing this and I was looking at
this positions with the pawn on A6 and I
was thinking you know okay maybe what
should then switch to not necessarily D4
but also C4 as well you know you have
lots of levers to open up that
particular side of the the boards and I
thought it was just a very very
complicated
yeah there's different types of
complicated right sometimes it's kind of
just a total mess where you have to
calculate your way through to the truth
here it's like you probably need even
more time you need like hours and hours
to kind of get to grips with the exact
Pawn structure both sides want the exact
piece trades uh either side once and
meanwhile not a bet gets up from the
board
yeah this one is a different type of
complex and I think this one's a harder
one to understand than most uh kind of
forcing lines most calculation type of
positions
yeah I think B5 just closed down that
side of the board but maybe that's a
small gain for white it feels like the
white Bishop's lengthened its diagonal
at the same time there are not much of
an option for black
E5 on the board played
absolutely and you pick you guys have
been getting your prediction Game Spot
on I think it's like I wasn't see that
Anish Gary has followed your advice by
also playing G5 as recommended Best Buy
test
yeah thank you you're happy everywhere
they're just pushing points they don't
even care anymore just pushing
importance it's the modern day Modern
Way of Chess right push those pawns
forward and uh well disregard the
consequences
you win some you lose some is not it's
not about results who needs to Castle if
you're Fabby when you can push pawns
okay really Tense one here this one will
explode at some points you get the
impression but yeah this just nicely
fizzling at the moment
where to go next so we have a few
options so there's obviously Sharks game
against Wesley and Ali Reza against
hikarish I I vote for Shaq
yeah we'll go to our reporter on the
ground shortly we'll go and check in on
how Nakamura is doing but yeah for now
managerov against Wesley so we quite
liked White's chances the question is is
that still the case yeah
see sharks just stirring off at the
screens in the tournament Hall not
looking at the board right now this one
has changed by a few moves since we were
last here let's just jump and do a quick
action replay of the uh yeah of what's
happened
and uh here we see white has a pawn and
A4 where it has a rook on D1 but it was
here that we left it after Queen to E2
hitting the Rook C4 was played Rook D1
this was captured B5 as predicted and
just two more moves A4 putting some
pressure on this black pawn chain backed
up now by A6 and queen B2 Judith a
direct threat on a pawn how to deal with
it
do we release the pressure do we just
defend that pawn
now for example it's a big question what
happens if B takes A4 I'm wondering is
it some blunder with black if black
takes is it Queen B6 for example that
white can
do or what is the something maybe Knight
between B6 is not good after all because
I thought takes takes Rook B8 and then
Rook d8 winning piece but I think the
black black has a great fast spawn on A4
yeah so for example after Knight takes
C8 you have to be careful about how
you'll stop this Runner uh maybe in this
position we don't get tempted by the big
piece we just get rid of one of the
pawns I'm not sure A4 Pawn or C4 Pawn
I'm too scared when I see an apron
running against the Knight it never ends
well for the night so let's see if after
B takes a fork win B6
is it really a good alternative because
black cannot move the bishop out because
then Queen d8 and Knight E7 winning
material
check the Rook drops
so if black cannot go for that one after
Queen B6 you must be going away with the
queen
yeah I'm slightly worried my Rook is
trapped no
in the corner
hmm
just to point out some flashy tactics
there's also a move like Knight F6 check
and uh I win your queen
yeah so Queen B6 mystery at the moment
this is the type of position that I
would just stop calculating if I Wesley
and I think it's too scary but maybe
there's a way to defend
maybe the queen goes to a more active
Square what's more active
E5 Queen G5 Maybe
G5 Knight East Knight C7 and now I can I
can jump out and counter attack and then
free my Rook oh
that's uh a nice shot tricks
tricks are plenty I got lucky there I
forgot about Knight C7
um but
yeah Queen B2 this is the key position
in the in the game if black can take
this Pawn you would love to get away
with it because you might even actually
gain some winning chances for the first
time in the game but it could also
backfire tactically yeah oh this one is
also heating up really nicely but I'd
like to go back to the bird's eye view
because there is a big moment now in the
game between Ari antari and Magnus
Coulson because Magnus has put his foot
forward in the center and broken out
with the pawnbrake D5 so it's a critical
moment
yeah usually if you can get Pawn breaks
in this type of Hedgehog formation uh
that kind of Magnus adopted early on
just curling up into a ball a little
prickly ball if you can break out in the
center it tends to favor you but the
question is are things just fizzling out
uh we're just going to see a bunch of
Trades and equality or is that is there
still life left around capturing a pawn
in the center
Judith first instincts on this big
decision I love to break out with D5 but
somehow usually it doesn't work
and it seemed like the only move which I
don't like in this position for white
that he went H3 giving a little hole on
G3 and weakness for later stage of the
game but I want to see how this
concretely going to be happening so if
we can dive into some of the lines after
capturing C takes D5 e takes D5 is on
the board what happens if white actually
takes on D5
yeah I think because Magnus have in mind
yeah good question I think Terry will
have to go for this he has to take
either with the Knight now or the pawn
on D5
um
yeah what is Magnus got in mind I'm
trying to look for tactics and trying to
look for tricks I don't see anything yet
it feels a bit shaky for white
but let's see he takes D5 yeah let's
jump in he takes D5
Knight takes D5
and now the first Junction do we trade
Rooks first or do we support go Bishop
D5 okay
don't well maybe you're right but I I
thought to go no maybe Rook C1 you're
right because Bishop C1 is not possible
so let's see Bishop C1 there's also a
pawn up for grabs as well yes yes I I
didn't forget about you two together
from don't worry about it but it's
coming in the next move okay
so now Bishop D5 and now
this is the first real opportunity to
grab that check it out Ivanka native
exactly yes yes yes
swings and roundabouts no I'm joking I'm
not actually going to be brave enough to
take that pawn I'm scared I'll get
trapped I mean A8 is also possible
the bishop B5 was the big idea that I
had you know I know how to defend my
extra Pawn
so Bishop A2 let's see what's going on
there there's also a nice C5 sometimes
yeah Bishop takes A2
but this feels like black fighting for a
draw no I don't know Knight C5 is in
there with the idea of Rook E3 okay true
true I wanted to trap your Bishop but
actually I'm not threatening it yet
because White's Queen is tied down to
this bishop on E3
and I see five just
and now it gets sharp if I drop back
then boom Rook takes E3 as you pointed
out Judith removing the defender of the
Knight and the black would win so yeah
maybe I was too pessimistic about
magnus's uh Dynamic possibilities here
what do we think should we Retreat let's
go back
he takes D5 just being played there by
Aryan we saw in the camera
the question is does black have anything
else do we have to take
on D5 I'll go for that variation quite
likely
I was trying to make a night jump work
Knight E5 Knight C5 but
somehow white is very well prepared
against those moves Queen on F2 Bishop
E3 the Knight moves away from the E4 and
then the B6 Pawn is under attack I don't
think there is uh there is a lot to be
done from Black's perspective
yeah we might then see a quick flurry of
moves
um I also saw in the feature chat just a
few minutes ago someone was asking where
Terry's Advantage disappeared and it was
just one of those positions according to
the computer he had an advantage but it
needed the right Maneuvers and he went
for a plan which allows this breakout
it's not a bad plan just uh maybe
equalizing that I had one question what
about B5
yeah I was also thinking about this it
reminds me of some casparov game where
he had a born on B5 and I came around to
B6 and took on D5 White House jumps like
Knight C6 however
well okay Knight C6 black takes twice
and then B4 move can be something but
there's white and also in these
positions after B for the D5 Square can
be very important for the Black Knight
yeah so Judith's uh highlighting B5 as a
potential opportunity for Magnus
and this is much more ambitious maybe
than just trading off the knights Rooks
and everything there's still like
tactical points in the air even after B5
so for instance you could play like Rook
CDD one
let's put this on the wood yeah
and then the move that I was thinking
about so you have to be very even now
you have to be you want to go B4
well that was my plan yeah but you know
maybe now you can go Knight C6
jumping hitting the queen let's say
black removes everything here
and what's the idea at the end C5 just
simply 95 yes and uh just say you know
what they say on the books
Bishop pair half a point Advantage I'd
be in heaven here
that's the only way I know how to win
games Bishop hair uh just to show our
White's Bishops they might not look too
impressive but long term if all the
queens or the Rooks come off the board
they will uh decide decide this game
interesting stuff maybe B5 but it could
backfire
yes indeed
it could certainly backfire and well
we're in for a very tense game but
Judith I just wanted to ask you if all
the pieces got traded off what are
magnus's chances to win were the black
pieces
well if if pieces are going to be get
traded off and we have the symmetrical
position with the pawns that is pretty
much uh equal kind of okay that's what I
was thinking as well that's going to be
very difficult for Magnus to massage a
victory from that
well big moment for the world world
champion I keep forgetting you know it's
been for such a long time he's been
world champion but no no more he's now
just playing
Grandmaster World rapid World Blitz
jumping yes in World rapid World Blitz
champion
yeah so I think we will leave Magnus to
ponder over his next decision whether to
trade everything off the board whether
to relieve detention or is there
anything more ambitious to do
and uh meanwhile yeah things are
progressing elsewhere between kukash and
giri it's down to the end game
things are opening up maybe in a clash
that we just left earlier abducator off
against Carolina and also big decisions
made in the game between farugia and
Nakamura Ivanka we're spoiled for choice
where to jump to oh okay you're giving
me the deciding vote I like it I think
we should check in on alireza and our
fourth commentator Hikaru Nakamura
yes and when we left that Clash we was
at least thinking Judith that Black's
position was easier to play for Rouge
ubunt even more time on the clock and
eventually made a decision he has re uh
positioned his Knight here and he's just
decided to trade off on F6 and now it's
Hikaru with the two tempting options
Bishop takes F6 or E takes F6
it's interesting uh alternative for
black Bose has its plus pros and cons
right because Bishop F6 still keeps
control over the E5 square and then
black might say that I'm not worried
about Knight E5 though at first I would
rather play probably with the capturing
with the phone
yeah capturing with the pawn may be more
harmonious for the pawn structure and
keeps this white knight from ever
leaping forward
that being said I guess the downside is
the blacks Bishop on G7 would then be
stuck behind its own Pawn for the near
future
yeah this is difficult it feels like
Bishop takes F6 is the dynamic one he
takes F6 is the kind of slower strategic
one yes indeed
I was vibing for Bishop takes F6
just because you know you can in a one
fine day try to get C5 and then try to
occupy the Santa with E5
yeah it's just a matter of taste I don't
think there's a right or wrong answer
here
that's a rough day but it's also of
course if you take with the bishop the
bishop is active and you can go with the
other Bishop E4 you put pressure on the
D4 pawn it can be C5 and if even if you
just give up a pawn that E5 so the
double Pawns in the center it can be
very powerful at the same time if your
opponent will stay back on C6 and the
other one on E7 and the D4 Pawn can
control both then maybe it's not the
best solution
for now the White Knight is on C2 still
not an optimal location for the Knight
and but it's also possible that after
Bishop F6 for example white wants to
jump to E3 and possibly even the bishop
moves away then Knight G4 can also show
up on that side but uh The White Square
Bishop for black it looks extremely
powerful later on on A4
yeah and uh well I didn't so you said
Pawn takes F6 David I mean I would
automatically my hand would take back
with the pawn but I would probably hate
myself for doing it
so I would not blame hikara if he's
feeling more vicious and takes back with
the bishop but yeah I'm
important guy he takes F6 here he takes
F6 and I was saying Bishop takes F6 and
I consulted the computer as a decider
Pawn takes F6
you guys completely right I mean it was
just saying capture the pawn and then
put the Rook on E8 and
just play chess is there a big
difference though Ivanka between the two
decisions
um I'm not a computer person so to speak
so I'm going to give you the evaluations
Pawn takes Pawn was plus
0.09 so in my language that means early
tiny tiny nudge better for white and
after Bishop takes it was 0.6
for white
so something tangible potentially and lo
and behold our fourth commentator our
reporter on the ground plays the best
move and uh okay instant reply there
from farrugia and this is maybe a big
decision to that he's allowing the black
queen to capture on B2 we've kind of
ignored the fact that this Pawn was on
priests for a while it's simply attacked
and I guess the idea is to meet Queen
takes B2 with a night jump to B4 when
the Black C6 Pawn might drop I think
it's very interesting to see that that
alireza in the last few moves he's just
not wasting time to move that pawn or
protect it with Bishop C3 and he feels
it and he felt it that the Knight on A3
is such a such an urgent matter to solve
that he is just not paying attention and
he wants to solve the problem in a
different way not defending but
counter-attacking right so this is the
case right now if black takes on B2 if
we can show that then the white knight
from C to finally activate itself and
plays Knight B4 and the Knight capture
on C6 will not be able to protect and
suddenly white starts to be active and
we have a Black's Bishop on G7 which is
uh very passive for the moment and the
F7 Knight is also something not uh so
happy even though he might jump very
soon to D6 and E4 or C4 so this is
something I think uh
Nakamura will avoid because he does not
want to see the Knight on C6
that being said how bad is it if uh I
play a really passive move here just
temporarily at least and play Knight d8
and say okay you can trade everything
off but
yeah I suddenly realized
you trapped me
how could you trap her majesty
Unstoppable wow and maybe there's a way
to get out I'm not sure Bishop before
yeah maybe you're trying to sneak out
but in human terms this is so scary the
queen cannot move and
yeah it takes nerves to steal which
Hikaru has of course but also
calculation powers to spot that this
queen does not get trapped after Rook to
B3 Bishop takes a knight and next moves
the black queen escapes again
it's certainly is awful and I just feel
that white is getting active and I've
one thing I've learned from observing
the top players is they don't like it
when their their opponents get active
with their pieces
oh well it's very intense right now in
these middle games and it's the perfect
time for us to take a break a little bit
of a breather but I have to mention to
you all about the 2023 speed chess
season beginning with the junior speed
Chess Championship on June the 13th this
four day event showcases the best young
talent in speed chess with over 45
000 on the line but the real prize goes
to the top finisher alone who moves on
to the main speed Chess Championship
later this summer catch all the actions
starting June the 13th right here at
switch.tv forward slash chess use x-clam
jscc in chat for all the details and
we'll be back soon with another
confessional from Hikaru who's bored
more of that on the back side of this
break
I have three puzzles here it's just him
yes yes no we're gonna oh but suddenly
you know there's like some kind of some
kind of triangles along the place okay
no okay why are no warning I'm not the
fastest so here is the first one okay
okay so F2 check yeah Eric A6 F2 png2
check Rook takes G3 Knight H3 King h100
was there like I made anything
yeah I think I have sold this already
like F2 is the answer
um actually I didn't have time to
calculate King takes F2 which looks uh I
mean at the very least I can just take
on D3 and then F1 and I'm much really
fat and and that is also to give to
Indian so it's just Checkmate but of
course the point is after look doesn't
matter which hook takes an episode then
that is Queen G2 okay
okay apparently blind all right your 10
seconds is up 100 yeah I just got it
while I was singing briefly yeah so it's
obviously off two and then uh Queen G2
90 strain Rook F1
wow okay so you're I mean there's also
Rook after HD2 the same thing yeah
yeah I mean Works off takes up to Queen
you two or two now you show King H1 and
then virtue one or two ones babe but
yeah
okay do you like to play and win or what
yes back to play away
mistakes
I don't know I didn't find the meat I
saw them
oh you're good I'll make them over yeah
unfortunately the move is not 92.
yes I think I'm gonna go find me F2
Rook takes oh F2 I need that warm up can
we start again
yeah yeah I need the warmer
um
if it was my it was a game I'll go 92
takes to 300 RC but I think it's that's
just special than an hour I don't think
it's a mate
yeah no I don't
all dead
um the correct move is actually F2
yeah
and then
oh wow like this
somehow it's unusual pattern but it's
really cool no exactly
that's so easy
[Music]
foreign
and before the break we did tease you
with a confessional from Hikaru who
confesses that he's bored let's have a
look
welcome back everyone so so we're here
once again today is round number six of
Norway chess um so as always I'll start
with the other games before I talk about
my own so magnus's game is kind of
interesting mag is assigned to play
Sicilian obviously was here in the
confessional box um before me he's
playing the Sicilian I mean Atari plays
Bishop B5 instead of sort of going into
the open Society now all those look kind
of normal but I'm a little surprised
that tari did not play Queen takes D4 in
general Queen D4 is much more principled
leads to a much more set kind of
position with very clear-cut plans for
both sides generally after Queen E4
block we play some E5 with Knight F6 or
H6 first in that order
um and it's much more Concrete in fact I
think Magnus might have played this
against vicious with the white piece or
something very similar so Atari playing
Knight takes D4 is a little bit
surprising I think the Atari
oops we played you the wrong one now
here's the real confessional from Hikaru
foreign
so first things first I noticed that
Magnus is already coming to confessional
blocks twice already pretty early in the
round and I'm feeling a little bit bored
so I thought it would follow the suit
um I mean everything that's been played
all prep nothing nothing new so it's
it's kind of boring and just in the back
room and wait or come in here and talk a
little bit more so I think I'll come in
and talk instead
um so my game again like I said it's all
standard expect D4 cd4c for D5 that's
that's was in the files that I reviewed
this morning so I'm expecting him to
play that again I'm not sure why he took
so long before playing it maybe he was
looking for some other original unique
setup as opposed to trying trying to
take some of the center with the pawn so
that's what I'm expecting my game mostly
other games I mean like I said nothing
has changed on nisha's game looks pretty
normal uh one thing speaking about Niche
that I noticed and this is where like
perception or paying attention
um or paying attention to details
matters a lot is I noticed that when a
niche walked by Fabiano's game against
notorbeck Anisha he looked at the scores
and he looked up at the sky and what
that tells me is that either Fabian
honors Bishop G4 F3 Bishop H5 is good or
it's a little bit dubious now based on
anisha's reaction as I saw when he's
walking by the board my general Instinct
was probably Bishop G4 H5 is not
considered the best line I think black's
supposed to go Bishop D7 so that's
probably why Anish was looking towards
the Congress he's like thinking I've
studied this Berlin but I'm not 100 sure
that this is the correct way to approach
it so that is one little observation
that I made in regards to the Fabiano
game against Notre back
um so what else is there Shaq actually I
kind of like his position against Wesley
he's got the bishop parent I assume that
in like in all positions in chess it's
probably completely fine for Wesley but
it feels maybe a little bit
uncomfortable potentially so shock maybe
will get something
um even though the position is fairly
balanced and of course magnus's game I
mean tar is trying to get this class
from Roxy bind with C4 and E4 and of
course we know Magnus plays this from
the white side and he loves it so much
with all that spatial with all the
spatial advantage in the center of the
board um but again it's going to be a
big fight so we'll see what happens
there so yeah all the games are going I
mean I feel very good right now I'm
still in prep I'm up 25 minutes you know
and you know I feel like good things
should happen but again we're very early
on so we just have to let the game
develop and go from there but uh
definitely another very very good start
considering the time control and
considering having the black piece so
I'm pretty happy so far
foreign
for those on-site comments I mean who
would have thought
Anish Anish walking past and revealing
some clues that maybe there had been
some good moves played
yeah the top players are very perceptive
we talk about body language here as
commentators and sometimes the viewers
say oh why but the players themselves
they admit that uh it's important it's
relevant for them too and Hikaru is
happy with his position although he was
feeling a little bit bored
well he was still in in prep right right
so what to do so yeah waiting your
opponent to make decisions oh exactly go
to your part-time job and do some
on-site reporting thank you very much
these other way around
to play the tournament is the
part-time job playing chess is his side
Hustle
talking about Chess full time
but it's actually incredible to you know
to think that he can
support professional streamer
and yeah he's number two in the world
we have look at some what action we have
in that position in his game he must be
not bored right now over there yeah
let's just shall we uh where should we
go guys yeah maybe we start with that
game just a quick recap on uh the last
couple of moves between ferrugia and
Nakamura that game has of course left uh
nakamura's preparation eventually uh
that's confessional from slightly
earlier in the day and we also left that
game just one move ago but one dramatic
move from both sides farrugia really
just uh trying to lash out here for
better or worse he's just broken forward
with B4 and uh just to backtrack one
move we talked about how the White
Knight wanted to use the B4 Square
therefore black prevented us with A5 and
B4 really trying to break forward with
this White Knight
and what do you make of this Judo is
this Panic is this uh well-founded
well I think uh the debate is really
going on about the B4 Square whether the
night can jump out from this very
passive position from C2 to B4 obviously
black is not going to capture on B4
because then it would be on White's
favor and you don't want what your
opponent wants to have on the board so
you want to do something different but
what can be done for example Bishop C2
to capture I would be considering that
first and if we dive into it and we
let's see the position after Bishop C2
Queen C2 a takes B4 it can be a
simplification by playing Queen C6 takes
the X takes on A2 and then to go Bishop
B4 and then it's a symmetrical position
but I would doubt that black would like
to go into this position and simplify it
this way so we have to find something
else for black after B4 I want to
highlight that there is a very important
C4 Square in the position suddenly which
is uh weakened so Knight D6 Knight C4
for example can be one of the
interesting
idea to take initiative like yeah I
loved your impression there Judith of
Hikaru himself takes takes takes it's
like listening to uh but yeah this is
very relevant potentially Knight D6 uh
one question is kind of whether you
allow this tension to persist or whether
you just lock things down you could
block things with A4 and later come in
for the square but then the White Knight
is freed up to maybe room towards the
king side towards the center instead
yeah just very very tense I've I've got
to admit I quite like this decision for
of B4 for Russia especially given kind
of the way the game's gone the time
situation it's kind of clarifying things
but if your car can keep the tension I
think uh black still has more than his
fascia of the chances
and uh Ivanka are your eyes being caught
elsewhere
yeah I I was also attracted to the game
between uh Abdullah and karuana
primarily because it's just as we called
it you know it's incredibly tense
position but white has broken out in the
center and both players are lining up
for everything to be happening on the
d-line
yeah and we have had quite a lot of
moves actually since we last left this
one but the general kind of outline of
the position is still the same white is
the one occupying the center with pawns
black is just kind of uh bracing for
impact black has sat with this nice kind
of locked up Pawn structure on the king
side in the center and he's saying okay
try and breakthrough if you can
who's gonna release his attention who's
going to crack first we asked this uh in
previous days but this is one of the
kind of definitions of a tense position
here well there is a huge tension in the
position by having the pawn on uh on the
E4 right and why did play H3 several
moves before so that's a full fixation
on the king's side so none of the
players the black Northern white they
really move their pawns on the king's
side so everything is happening in the
center of the of the possession of the
board the question is whether who wants
to give up and open up the position
right with the E Pawn you definitely
don't want to take on the E4 because it
gives extra opportunity for white even
to break out with F4 later on so if
black would like to exchange bones for
example it's only to consider C takes
d4c takes D4 and then Rook C2 for
example to be activating his Rook that
is something which looks quite tempting
for me playing it with black
or black can just simply keep the
tension first of all Knight F4 is always
something to consider or if black does
not want to have exchange of knights it
is also something to to think of I think
maybe B4 or Knight d8 and trying to get
to catch the A5 Pawn though white maybe
wants to close the position with D5 this
is somehow it's a it's a momentum in the
game I think that black has to make a
decision whether he opens up the
position opens up the C5 by playing C
takes D4 or keeps the tension
yeah and uh meanwhile it is abdicator's
movement it's hard to imagine what to do
how to improve the pieces the queen hard
to improve her the bishop Knight how to
improve them maybe Rook D2 starting with
the Rooks first uh just I want to
prevent your Rook C2 idea for black any
infiltration there uh maybe Rook D2 Rook
F to D1 and then decide from there I
have no idea but at least you're hinting
that you might open up the D file at a
later opportunity uh with the white
Rooks just D takes E5 bring the white
Rooks up but first you need a few prep
moves you need to uh get that ready for
later
Ivanka Judith who would you choose I
think white but
it's hard to imagine
a breakthrough her plan
I think this is a position where the
battle wins
true
it's often the case in chess it is often
the case but I'm gonna say
draw
I I think this position looks so tense
that I think we're going to read a
deadlock at some point and neither
player are going to be able to make
progress I can see the position getting
is so close that we're going to see all
16 pawns left on the board no trades
but it's not so easy to love the
position because I understand that the C
takes D4 Rook C2 wants to be the move
possibly but let's say if y pushes D5
then there is an opportunity for black
later on to move back with the Knight
wherever let's say to f8 regroup the
Knight to a good location and then F5
can be breaking out the opportunity for
black
yeah I I agree it's not that easy but I
think they'll manage it
that I'm being cheeky here
the two ambitious players they'll find a
way to uh open at least some lines some
squares for the pieces to jump to but
yeah take black okay I would take whites
so interesting and I say it's just even
Steven we're torn here we're caught in
the uh caught in two minds in the studio
let's give Abdul satorov some time to
think about which plan to pursue
meanwhile let's uh zoom out of this one
and go elsewhere shall we revisit the Q
cash at anishagiri game
that one has gone into the end game as
we saw but it's an interesting end game
you know with the poor majorities and
different sides of the board and again
who is better here it's very difficult
to tell
yeah this one uh hasn't changed too much
apart from the fact that black has
indeed created a past E Pawn as Judah
predicted this eporn currently Under
Fire but also one set of Rooks off the
board
and uh let's just jump in to show what's
happened what's changed in the last
three or four moves
so after white played Bishop A5 black
did indeed strike with G5 a few times
ago as Judith predicted creating this
past Pawn we saw a trade of Pawns
White's Rook centralized very logical
stuff F5 has predicted as well just
cementing this Knight and Knight to D6
saying that okay he's happy with all of
the trades all of the exchanges here go
cash one set of Rooks came off the board
Knight back to F6 Gary wants to keep
pieces on and rookie when uh rookie one
met by the tricky Knight to D5 now the
idea I guess is Rook takes E6 Knight E3
check and uh wherever the King goes
let's say D3 Knight takes G2 suddenly
some Knight Forks in the air also the F
Pawn is very quick to run so this was
dodged and after 95 G3
so this Pawn no longer Under Fire from
the Black Knight and E6 is hanging is
this an issue for Gary I don't
immediately see how to defend this Pawn
comfortably
somehow it seems like white is uh is
more active and the Knight and the
bishop stands very well for this uh open
position Rook stands very well attacking
the E6 spawn so now black has to be
smart somehow can he go F4 looking for
counter chances
well let's have a look because this is
the question
and there's quite a forcing idea as well
because
I don't see anything other than
eliminating that pawn on F4 otherwise it
will just push forward to F3 and become
very strong and then Rook takes was the
idea right and put a rook on F2 and give
a check actually there are several ideas
I think Bishop F4 is okay yeah double
attack but also Rook F4 makes a lot of
sense
yeah lots of options for simplification
after Rook E6 Bishop H2
yeah somehow I would still take whites
just because of the queen side majority
but it feels like it should feel
dreaming I'm a dreamer
but I'm not the only one
you almost carried it on there Judith
before we break out into song let's go
back to the chest F4 we are expecting
and uh I think Gary should pull the
brakes now
try and fizzle this one out before uh he
can imagine that things get worse
oh nobody caught that okay therefore
we're expecting and yeah I think this
one both players both uh sides have just
played equally well
maybe bishop E3 is also something to
think of what is
okay ambitious playing for the win
exactly whether it's playing for a win
it's just uh trying to find another
alternative also for black that could be
also
something that Anish is thinking of yeah
and uh check out this stat from Rocket
Man twitch says world number one is a
poker player number two is a streamer
number three is a fashion designer I
mean
do we have any professionals at the top
three number four is a podcaster that's
true Abby
yeah it shows chess players sometimes
it's questioned do they have other
skills you know just chest translate to
life clearly it does
well I think it means that the chess is
transforming as a sport
right New Opportunities and new things
what the players likes to try out
yeah multitasking though I don't know
how they do it keeping up such a high
level despite pursuing other interests
and it's Anish number five because he
could be the Tweeter
I don't think he is uh
world champion and this is going on the
live ratings according to uh how things
stand as of this very moment of course
those standings could be shaken up and
meanwhile we see an issue on the camera
he did play F4 we are expecting those
simplifications and maybe our streamer
uh predicted that Hikaru said very early
on that this game might fizzle out
towards a draw it's heading in that
direction unless uh just barring a big
mistake right now
okay oh I want to go next some more
stats number five as a lawyer it's true
number six is a data player
I can tell you that if you have any
chess players around number 60 is a
commentator
yeah it's
multi-talented these top uh these top
guys
okay where to go next
it's in mamajarov's game for some time
can we jump over there just to see what
we can expect in this game because there
were some simplification and black
becomes somehow pretty active there yeah
black has become very active uh Wesley
so he's trying to defend this position
we thought it was the two result games
suddenly uh things have opened up and
the big question is can white and should
white take this bishop off the board
that's the main imbalance in the
position right now Knight for Bishop
do you change that structure it weakens
the black king maybe but it might lower
your winning chances if the Queens ever
disappear from the board
what do you think Judith well I don't
know before I was really happy for
White's possession because it seemed
like white is pressing and white is more
active and now I don't feel this anymore
because black has a very good setup for
The Rook on B8 Queen on A5 supporting
the B5 phone which wants to be pushed
just did a second I think in the next
move and I don't see how it can be
stopped only if maybe you go Rook B1 but
it's not something you really want to do
I have a way to stop it
you go Knight takes Bishop of course
let's jump in
and then it's very simple chess but I
think it could be quite effective if you
put the Rook on D7
and uh okay obviously you can't play B4
because Pawn takes pawn and oops the
queen on B2 is on a wonderful diagonal
hitting at G7 so don't touch that one
and you know I I've Sunset the pawn on
B5 could be potentially weak because you
can't actually challenge The Rook on D7
with any Rook dates because you do give
up the pawn on B5
yes this is a critical move Knight takes
and Rook D7 how strong is The Rook on D7
will be
and I like to make it strong right
because you'll have to we're actually
move the queen to D2 and then centralize
I think like is one option is for
example to go Queen B6 check
yes and then Rook fa Rook F7 and the
other one maybe does the best it's
better instead of check to go Rook A8
immediately
okay after uh Rook day seven okay yeah
it's threatening to exchange on A1 and
once you go out with the King
very good let's say HT well only H2
because if H1 then Rook A7 and then when
takes the X cream B5 Queen A1 and C3 but
can you just say I play Queen D2
actually yeah Queen D2 yeah
and after okay seven
then we think again
yeah unfortunately once Black's
protected the seventh rank it's hard to
imagine any breakthrough a check you
simply hide I wanted to play like a
sneaky move like E5 and try to check you
from this angle but somehow it feels
like the black queen should be able to
cover maybe just a simple check and
queen to B1 just to cover this diagonal
um
feels close for white somehow but not
close enough
in these six 26 Queen F oh I was gonna
say queen of five Rook f a rook f8 and I
block Maybe
hmm
Rooks coming off the board should lead
to a draw
yeah wins coming off the board should
also lead to a draw
um you have King H1 on the board what a
prophylactic going out from that
diagonal you know what he wants here he
wants a trick if B4 he's gonna take and
hope you play Queen takes because then
Rook to d8 check deflecting uh the black
rook and winning a piece
it's a cheap trick but a relevant trick
maybe now yeah either Rook takes Rook
will happen or the black queen would
drop so okay nice move what about B4
what is his plan okay and if I take you
take this
okay
hmm could could you fiddle the move
order just a little bit so instead of
Pawn takes Pawn you could throw in I'm
obsessed Knight takes bishop and then
Pawn takes Pawn
okay thanks anyway yeah
yes
and that's as far as I got
yeah maybe there he's he would be trying
Queen C3 yeah just to
well but I don't see what is the threat
Rick D7 is not even a threat because of
root B1
let's say Rook A4 just breaking the PIN
well I can keep the Queens on but it's
not easy to break through I might just
come back maybe even C3 there just stop
pushing the pawn Black's King will just
hide safely on H7
this game should be fine for Wesley
and
just to kind of visualize a very happy
ending for white what would happen if it
were a rook ending and white managed a
miracle to win the C4 Pawn
let's say a check yeah let's pretend
that black can't play Rook A4 or Rook A1
check can come behind
let's say black just Waits
uh this one's some winning chances I do
believe because the E6 Pawn is weak and
isolated
if the E6 Pawn was maybe back on F7 then
should be a draw but
yeah this is the dream scenario for
white for Shaq right now it's just hard
to imagine Wesley blundering upon and
Wesley deep in thought
Judith do you think he'll play B4 or
just to simplify everything immediately
well I think he will because there is
not much to play for with black in this
position
so why not to simplify it yeah active
defense tends to be the way if the
players can work out that there's
nothing wrong with it I think Wesley
will go for this move
and uh yeah before it looks like it
equalizes hard to imagine white winning
that game
should we check out
oh which one to go for maybe Magnus yeah
because you guys mentioned the word
simplify
and that is the game where things are
fast
simplifying at least
the Ricks have left the board the apron
has disappeared
oh this Magnus gonna grab the A2 Pawn we
predicted all of this dude actually uh
up to this point and you were here
before we've been here before and Magnus
okay he doesn't go for one of the moves
we were predicting he doesn't recapture
that uh Pawn that he's just dropped he
doesn't take on A2 with the black Bishop
instead he improves The Black Queen
hitting uh White's Bishop on E3 and
throwing the move back to White
interesting I didn't expect this one
I've got to say but I like the look of
it
she's just asking questions he's asking
white pieces to maybe put themselves on
Clumsy squares white has grabbed a pawn
of course on A6 but now White's Bishop's
slightly vulnerable to some hits by kind
of with Knight C5 here the bishop
immediately attacked I like what Magnus
has done as well because with the queen
on d8 he was likely running into Rook C8
where the Rooks would have come off the
board as well and if Rooks had left I
think the winning chances for Magnus
would have dwindled uh massively so
Queen 63 how to guard against this
do we move the bishop do we defend the
bishop can you still simplify
Ivanka that's cynical but maybe good
Rook C8
consistent at least well but there might
be something tactical I think right MCA
takes takes Knight C5 and the bishop can
uh end up in trouble
yeah let's jump in because things are
becoming very forcing despite the fact
that it is simplifying uh Rook C8 just
gets the Rooks off the board and shoot
it's pointing out take take Knight C5
one more move just Queen anywhere and
this bishop is
falling
yeah I could definitely see Aryan
getting scared here I would be scared
here as white as well and like these
three is a threat Knight B2 E3 Bishop
can be vulnerable so this is something
to
look after with white because there is
no Harmony between pieces right now the
C8 Bishop is very much out of that is
that is very true but I do feel like we
have to be a little bit concrete here
and uh
because after all it is a pawn
[Laughter]
that's true we've got to fight to the
end anything for that one Pawn Advantage
aren't you suspicious that you have an
extra phone and the bar is still only
but you know 50 against Magnus I I will
take that
um and meanwhile we have a different
move so not Rook to C8 instead if we go
back he's just played Bishop D2 Ariane
um so okay dodging and maybe he wants to
trade this way with rookie one maybe
slightly more harmonious way to do it
his Bishop no longer trapped
gotta be happy here I I am happy uh
I am very happy but I do feel that the
A2 Pawn is living a Charmed Life
Yep this Pawn can be whipped off the
board if Magnus wants
to bring that porn with the playing Rook
A8 and with the Rook
and then Rook C8 that would be losing
the extent Quincy yeah I was joking it's
just
a bad move maybe we put this on the
board actually it's quite a relevant one
uh wow on the board okay rookie eight
just played and uh here I was plundering
with Rook to C8 uh let's show this if
Ariane gets two uh kind of too
simplistic then Rook C8 loses a piece to
Queen C5 double attack and not just a
double attack if the white Bishop takes
this Black Knight then
skewer so okay rookie eights from Magnus
how to deal with this
well in the last several moves I think
black took over the initiative a bit I'm
not saying black is better but having
the bishop centralized and it's on D5 it
gives a lot of uh hopes and comfortable
position for black especially if black
will be able to capture on A2 with the
Rook so there are some inconvenience for
white yeah
I mean for example if I Retreat the
whole way back let's run away with the
bishop because because a scaredy cat
nice and safe Rick takes porn let's say
I play Move Like Bishop C3 how bad can
this be
for white
I don't know this Rook on A2 is a bit
stuck
if the B2 Pawn is well defended
I I think that's the perfect way
actually to play the position because
otherwise White's King could be shaky
Bishop F1 like it and then Bishop C3
just reinforced the loose piece on D4
yeah if black could get one more move
maybe Knight C5 Knight A4 try and chop
off this bishop on C3 if you get the
bishop pair you're probably just winning
on the darts Quest well probably you
want to go back rookie one and also
Knight B5 can be interesting to
eliminate the black Square Bishop which
is usually you can give some unpleasant
the thoughts if it should be five H4
controlling the black square but
probably that will be not allowed for
for uh Magnus yeah I love that move
actually Knight B5 Judith there just uh
yeah training off Black's best minor
piece potentially
Yeah the more pieces that leave the
board the closer weight gets to safety
but
Magnus having the fun do you think
Ariana might get a bit nervous in this
position in this position after Rook A8
potentially you know we do talk about
the Magnus effect and how people just
act like they're caught in the
spotlights and they just can't think but
I do feel that Ariane has uh 43 minutes
to navigate the complications
and he will be able to do it he's an
excellent player I mean I don't feel
that his score really reflects the level
of his play
I agreed and uh Aryan on his day is
extremely strong extremely tenacious
tactically sharp and this is the type of
position where
can't go that wrong unless you do
blunder tactically right I don't know
I'm not sure I can say that I like the
move Bishop B5 Because unless there is
something very concrete the bishop I
think stands better as you suggested
David Bishop F1 it's just simply much
more safer safer it's guarding the back
Rank and on B5 it can get also in
trouble sometimes yeah and it's taken
away your knight B5 resource for later
on
the bishop standing on a square the
White Knight might want to use so now it
feels like Bishop C3 just cling on hold
all the squares
and the game continues and I found it
super interesting when we had Maurice
Ashley in the studio he was talking
about looking at those connection
connection points you know like like you
would look at the put night on D4 and
the bishop on B5 and so you would hone
in on like squares like C5 and B4 just
as a Target
yeah let's use different colors there
I'm using red too much on the board so
uh c5b4 maybe if the Queen ever lands on
these squares safely the pieces could
get attacked and yeah it does feel a bit
loose
um these pieces here especially the
Knight and Bishop
feels like they're hanging in the air
slightly defended by the White Queen
right now but yeah tactics will maybe
happen later on you know I see some
crazy idea I'm gonna share with you I
don't think it's good but it's funny
crazy is always good Judith you can
count on me on that one your Bishop C3
for example Apple there might be an idea
to play Bishop H6
okay rookie want to go Rook A1 wow okay
one you're trying to lure me away
and Bishop E3 would be it I'm not sure
at all that it works Bishop E3 and after
Rook a
little rookie 8 is covered argue
discovered yeah I'm defending the square
so no checks on the back rank but why is
this winning for white
hmm
maybe it's just too many pieces if you
go Rook A7
ah rookie seven yeah so the B5 Bishop is
great
I haven't seen this all in advance just
to show this position black is off a
queen for rook and Bishop but this pin
will most likely NAB the Black Knight
and we have Bishop C3 on the board
actually yeah this would be easy to
blunder or misevaluate
you don't want to move away your Bishop
from G7 unless really there is some
concrete good stuff
yeah so you think after Bishop C3 Bishop
H6 won't appear on the board
but a nice idea
and okay well that is looking like it's
a very fighting game with Magnus piling
on the pressure but we have had a new
confessional from our man on the ground
Hikaru Nakamura so let's go there and
see what he has to say about his own
game
well hello everyone welcome back so I
think I think that my game's gotten a
little bit a little bit messy
um I'll just just cut right to the chase
I think that probably this this whole
opening was fairly balanced I think
objection I probably should have taken
on F6 was a bishop in retrospect and not
the pawn but due to the time situation
and just the general peace place and I
kind of want to keep the game going or
so so I thought I have a feeling that
might be a little bit worse here now
um because I've you know trying to play
on the board and on the clock and
everything else and try to go for Glory
um still very still very complicated
though but I have a feeling that I'm
slightly worse if he plays as precisely
that being said of course it's very much
headed towards uh slot Fest as I like to
call towards the end of the game I mean
I think we're both I mean I'm still up
about 17 18 minutes nearly 20 minutes
but it's getting to the point where
moves are going to start happening a
little bit quicker and I think I've done
something wrong but still if I can get
this Knight to D6 and E4 maybe maybe B5
I think I'm probably completely fine
um then it's going to come down to
weather
he can maneuver a night to this D3 and
then C5 Square no longer has the B3
Square because that's what the pawn and
A4 starts with the pawn and A4 could
also be a weakness depending so it's
still very very choppy very very hard to
judge what's going on I mean I think
what I'm aiming for is to go Bishop f8
96 and put an item B5 if I can't or on
e4 and if he has to take trade his
Bishop from for my knight I mean if I
get the two Bishops it's hard to believe
it can be all that scary
um but I have a feeling in this current
moment there's like the next move or two
there's probably some Advantage for
white something that I've that I've
allowed him to do um I don't see it of
course so obviously I think I think I'm
okay but I feel like if he's able to
find some excellent moves it could be
kind of unpleasant for maybe he's not
able to find something I have a feeling
that I'll be able to untangle and just
end up a little bit better as we head
into the home stretch but still very
very very uh unclear and I would say
that overall I'm definitely less happy
than I was uh half hour 45 minutes ago
yeah Hikaru they're telling us that he's
unhappy with his position
and saying that he feels like he's
slightly worse he is regretting
capturing that pawn on F6 with a pawn
and instead thinking about the time
that's gone before and thinking well he
should have played Bishop takes F6 and
kept those Dynamic possibilities alive
do we agree with uh hikaru's pessimism
like completely understand why he has
this feeling because white has this bone
structure having the quote on A3
defending the B4 so why it really
improved his position quite a bit from
the Knight A3 it's on E3 it's still not
the perfect optimal uh place for the
night because what Hikaru was explaining
also that this is the question whether
white will be reaching out to D3 with
one of the knights and reaching to C5
so that that makes the difference for
the outcome of the game whether one of
the knights can really reach the
destination of C5
but we could see that Hikaru was not
happy he was only talking about his game
which also meant that he's starts to be
engaged with his game only maybe and not
really following the others what they
are doing but uh yeah white has a very
nice position I believe
and the other point Hikaru mentioned
pertains to this exact moment and I
guess the key decision for alarisa is to
take or not to take and my first
instinct here was not to take but the
more I think about it
actually maybe Knights are just Superior
to Bishops because the center is blocked
the queen side is blocked and nice
Knights do thrive in these kind of
blocked locked structures blacks Bishops
will take a long long time to have any
real influence in the game whereas at
the moment this Black Knight especially
He also mentioned the maneuver of
planting it on B5 this would maybe solve
a lot of Black's issues long term
and okay farouza he's made a move he's
taken that Knight off the bud
do we approve I I approve because I can
visualize the future with a white knight
on C5 and I don't see how
white is just simply not
slightly better I don't want to say
batter because I do feel that black has
got good resources but
it's good
yeah well he's going got on the safe
side I must say that he he might still
squeeze
Hikaru his Knight on E3 covers F5 Square
so after he's doubling on C2 black is
not able to regroup his Bishop F5 to E4
which is important
uh the black Bishop on G7 does not have
a good power in this game anymore
because black cannot play F5 because E5
Square would be weakened and uh pretty
much the idea for white is to type the
the D6 Rook to the C6 phone so after
Rook C2 white wants to go I believe
Knight E1 and really straightforward
with a direct flight to go Knight D3 and
Knight C5
yeah almost Unstoppable now this plan so
Nakamura needs to arrange his pieces he
knows the Knight is landing on C5 within
three or four moves so he's got three or
four moves to kind of set up his army in
anticipation uh
there's one way to deal with that uh
threat is that you could put pressure on
the D4 Pawn
yes but I think white can also make
extra moves before going with the Knight
to D3 because bite can go Rook C2 also
it can occupy with the Rook the C5
Square Rook to C5 and then play Queen C2
and that would be an incredible powerful
battery there because the queen from C2
puts pressure on the C6 and on the A4
phone and maybe only after that the
White Knight will be taking its Journey
Yeah the more I look at it it feels like
one-way traffic or it sounds like
one-way traffic uh the way we're framing
this how does black set up those
defenses then how do we think uh
Nakamura is going to
get ready for all of those plans
have any way of creating counter play on
the king side I was just looking at that
I was thinking well maybe the problem is
that the A8 Rook is tied to the defense
of the A4 Pawn
and The Rook on D6 doesn't present a
pretty picture either so it's and
somehow you kind of want to go pushing
with the pawns but two pawns by
themselves are not a scary impression so
I'm not sure I'm not sure Hikaru has the
means to initiate that King side attack
I have the feeling that maybe black
should be playing Bishop H6 and
optionally eliminate the E3 Knight in
order to have an activation option for
the bishop on F5 to E4
yeah it looks definitely possible but uh
I don't know Bishop has it takes a lot
of kind of mental control to give up one
of them
you can't give up Division I just I
wouldn't be physically incapable I think
I would my hand would uh would just
never allow me to chop off this night on
E3 but of course Hikaru will play the
position if that's the best way if
that's the only way then he'll play it
um yeah it feels like as well this
bishop wants to be sitting on the Square
that The Rook is occupying but I don't
think you have enough time to kind of
Shuffle around and kind of re-purpose
your rook and uh relocate the bishop on
D6
yeah I do now understand why Hikaru was
so at least why he sounded so worried uh
in the confessional
momentum looks to be on white side it
went from easy to play with black to
very straightforward for white now and
it's much easier to play it with white I
believe because white is the one who is
going to be put pressure on black spawns
a rook C2 it's very obvious that it's
going to be there and of course rookie 2
has double idea not only roxy2 but
immediately making space for the Knight
to E1 and D3
yeah
my car he mentioned as well he had a
small time Advantage but that has
disappeared mostly it's down to around a
five minute difference between the two
players now as we approach that crunch
time uh the critical phase of the game
that he mentioned still 18 moves to make
before they get to the time control
this one is going to be a scramble it
certainly is and we always have to
mention that Norway chess is a very
unique time format which basically means
the players are playing without
increment until they reach past move 40
and then they will only get a 10 second
increment per move which means that once
the time scramble hits you don't get out
of it you're stuck there for life and uh
I mean
this is me Mrs optimism
and anyhow
but I mean to certainly I mean if the
action starts to hit around those type
those time controls you know move 40 or
something then we are going to see a lot
of mistakes being made and someone is
going to crack
yeah and at this very moment it feels
like it's easier to crack as black
that's that's the issue so uh okay let's
leave Hikaru to ponder what to do next I
don't envy him this Choice things are
changing elsewhere the game between Mama
jar of and Wesley so has pretty much
gone along the lines that we predicted
likewise with gokash and Gary where
peace is just flying off the board maybe
we'll see a result there in the near
future
but I was wrong uh if you take a look at
the game between nordeback of
desertified Fabiana caruana I was like
ah yeah you know it has 16 pawns will be
on the board they'll find a way to keep
it on and it'll be a long maneuvering
game we'll just finishing a draw well I
was completely wrong I held up my hands
and say that a set of Pawns have left
the board and white does have the
makings of some counter play on the
d-line
yeah let's just jump into that game we
see the players on the camera here and
do satorov with white his last move
looks very logical he's just dropped
back with the White Queen but we can see
with this graphic on the board
across a Red Cross not approving of that
move a missed opportunity that means and
not finding the key idea maybe there was
something better maybe there was
something more direct for Abdus this
game looks roughly balanced very blocked
still and I'm wondering what he could
have played what he should have played
instead okay well I was a naughty and I
I peaked and the engine is simply saying
D5
okay that is a difficult move to play
for a human let's just jump in and show
that point D5 on the last move Judith
well especially after doubling the Rooks
on the D file D5 seems to be not a
logical move to say this least
yeah what could the idea be here it
looks like you're simply blocking things
up black can jump either back with the
Knight or maybe even forward
let's say
should we believe two engines
in such a position that's what I'm
thinking you know I'm thinking that the
engine is just kind of
it's one of these bugs that compute
engines have that you know when one
plays D5 grabs bass it's like I love it
you're doing beautifully but in reality
I mean how how wonderful is this
position so for instance after Knight
takes
or Bishop takes Knight oh it's not
Knight takes night uh yeah hang on
Knight F4 it is Bishop takes Knight I
should discuss let's say black
recaptures
yeah it's puzzling to me because I think
the old stereotype 20 years ago would
have been okay block position don't
trust the computer ever 10 years ago so
sometimes trust the computer in Block
positions now it's like okay computers
always know best no matter the structure
but here it does seem to be
yeah it's basically saying pull and grab
on with cream to be six ah wow okay so
just ignoring all strategic factors just
going for a simple Pawn on a six but
even then
this feels very inhuman to allow it yeah
I mean for example if black plays a move
like Rook to B8 you're happy to just
park your queen on A6
porn up you're trapped for now but HCA
exactly
one
yeah I guess just Rook C1 and there's no
way to actually trap uh her majesty over
on E6 here we'll see one for white but
you can see from a human point of view
why this would firstly not even be on
the radar but secondly be hard to
evaluate with the White Queen sidelined
yes but don't forget that after D5 there
is also another idea just to move back
with the Knight to f8 for example yeah
in 1908 there is no mate not an f8 yeah
just coming around
it's puzzling I must admit why the
engine loves white so much here but okay
let's jump back to the game Let's back
head back to reality and uh we see Rook
h8 was met by Queen E1 a bit of a Miss
maybe objectively but Rook C4 the last
move now on the board
well black wants to make sure that after
d takes E5 D takes E5 the B4 Pawn is
under attack so after Rook D7 black and
capture that
yeah Rook D7 and this Pawn will fall so
okay this is the current game position
hmm
what to do about this threat uh often it
is just attacked anyway still you've got
to be careful when you take it as black
indirectly the queen might defend B4
what are your
uh eyes drawn to here you have anchor
Judah what moves come to mind it's not
obvious for me
well rugby4 is a threat so Rook D3 seems
to be the most logical defending the B4
and keeping the option to open up the
position and also maybe Knight C3 at
some point
yeah I I was also drawn to that simple
idea but I must admit my eyes were
swayed by more complicated ideas of such
as Knight C1
to try to like use tactics so that the
Rook does take oh
the bar didn't hate it
so my idea was after Rick takes Pawn to
capture on E5
the one trick pony and then like Rook D7
of these yes
nice cutting the coordination between
the queen and Rook so now White's Queen
is attacking this rook and if that Rook
moves Rook takes Knight wins due to this
pin on the seventh rank
cannot allow the opponent to get so
active yeah maybe Knight C1 and uh the
Knight I guess would be headed around
maybe B3 or D3 I hadn't got that far I
just thought I was just working out what
happened after Knight C1 and that was it
maybe black should be playing doubling
The Rook on the C file in that case
[Music]
for example when I see one rook hc8 and
the game goes on
uh yeah Black's very active with his
Rooks it's just about whether white can
compensate for that now
okay
still super tense just as tenses when we
left it a bit earlier on despite the
fact the C file has opened
and earlier you said black Judith you
were taking uh fabi's position still
um
pivot I'm okay with it
I'm pivoting completely I'm liking
White's position actually and uh the
more I'm looking at my movement I see
one the more I'm kind of liking it
because I'm thinking well the Knight can
actually reroute itself after like to
Knight D3 and then you can plop
something on C5 obviously you'd have to
do initiate some trades in the center
first
yeah and then eventually the White
Knight might get to the C5 Square the
destination takes a few moves but uh
definitely possible and Fabi gets up
from the board let's leave Abdus to
think about this one and just because
there's some action at least temporarily
before the game Fizzles out should we go
to gakesh against Anish giri
um
as far as I see that yeah maybe for not
for long but let's see what Anish has in
mind in counter chances
anisha's given up a pawn I've been
talking about White's Queen side
majority for the last three hours
finally there's two past pawns but is it
enough that's the question for gokash
and uh giri wouldn't give up a pawn
unless he'd worked it all out right
minimal material left on this board a
few pieces
whites pieces as well very far from the
black g-pawn that's running
but the king can do the chasing of that
g Pawn right so if you were to
play some random move like B3
or maybe even Bishops yeah beef yeah I
was yeah before now that the bishop I
spot that the bishop can go to B6
mhm
just start running with the white points
yeah
okay he's reaching for it B3 oh
why not B4 well maybe he wants to bring
back the bishop or leaves the option to
come back to E1 after G3 King E3 he
wants to go King F3 and possibly go
Bishop E1 later
or maybe he forgot the pawns can move
two squares on the first go
yeah maybe it's not the stage of her
it's not quite at a kind of Breakneck
speed race yet you don't need to rush
with your pawns forward maybe it's the
white a pawn that he wants to push later
on uh but a niche okay how is he gonna
justify giving up that extra Pawn the
good thing for him is as black if he
gives up the bishop for White's two
remaining pawns or the Knight for two
white two remaining pawns it will be a
draw
but uh yeah that's a big if
okay should we jump in with some
variations let's see because uh it is
getting very interesting if white can
stop the G Pawn then after all we can
deny white has an extra phone and to
pass spawns
so we think black's play here the
counter play is predicated on this G
Pawn running forward let's say G3
and okay which moves oh King E2 working
E3 but for some reason I don't know I'm
happy to go King E3 okay on to dark
Square oh
yeah beautiful E2 is more logical I
understand but yeah still the same path
towards this Pawn
yeah I was just to show it nasty Shrek I
could play Bishop D4 check it doesn't do
anything you won't take me of course you
won't allow me to run through to Glory
but uh just to show deflection tactics
sometimes work but King F3 and you
maybe Corral this one maybe even win the
spawn and win the game
and we saw the evaluation bar it did
react after this G3 move which in
analysis you want to play first of all
uh but G3 may be a big mistake maybe you
have to bring your king simply to come
King F7 King E6 King D5
okay
centralization over everything
King F7
yeah
okay I like that featured chat I think
it's uh
linking to Doctor Strange the Marvel
movie there but uh
showing my nerd side
um King F7 Bishop E1 Judith or Bishop B6
which diagonal do you want to occupy
with the white Bishop I don't know why
it should be going for A4 right A4 and
then re grouping the bishop uh what
about also about activating the Knight
just uh you know exactly uh killing the
plan of k6 G3 uh now don't play King E3
because my tactic Works yes in E3 I will
check you the problem is that G2 is next
yeah after King E2 yeah uh G2 same thing
yep yeah and okay this will just end in
a draw after a bishop check
and not enough material left even
without the white pawns this is a simple
draw
hmm
so we can't go Knight C5 cut I can't get
these pieces back into the game
as we try at least
A4 bishop move
I'm really attracted to moving the
bishop budget should be one yeah I just
don't know why just uh
instinct which B16 now at least
um I can give a check but
I'm happy if I yeah five square you're
happy
maybe you're happy either way uh King D5
and suddenly yeah if I could just get
back to E4 or some Central Square with
the white knight I'd be loving life but
there we go Anish following your
prediction Judah
yeah when in doubt bring the king good
end game uh kind of motto to have
a niche following that wisdom yeah and I
think it's the perfect time to take a
break to rest and get yourself a cup of
coffee because more action is in store
and there we can see the tension
building up in the game between good
cash and Anish Anish is down a pawn and
he needs to justify that quickly and uh
anyhow we're gonna take a break and we
will see you shortly in a few minutes
I have three puzzles here yeah I don't
think I'll be much easier than this okay
I get the warm up yep 10 seconds all
right and let's see this one but um
yeah that's pretty straightforward I
think
yeah that's I mean it's obviously uh
Bishop D2 King A5 or K3 Bishop A4 Queen
takes B7
oh it is not it's not I'll give you a
second try
really and also five seconds if you want
to look at 40. no I don't need to I
didn't ah because there's a there's a
rook G3 truck that I missed this this is
true um okay just give me one side when
I think about this
yeah I'm not gonna get it without
actually thinking so you can just tell
me what it is okay it is uh Queen to
Africa first
okay okay yeah I was I would have had a
thing for like a couple of minutes to
get that that's that's that's actually
pretty tricky
yeah I think I found it completely
it is not Bishop D2
okay let me try again I know the
position is
okay
this one is going to be more the shipur
of course
um
so I'm thinking about Queen F3 right now
I'm not sure Bishop takes and only the
image of the two so that there is no
roof G3
yeah okay I will stay with queen of free
the first move and after Mission Texas
the beautiful one yeah yeah you're
you're nailing this one
ah okay okay I think um I think I this
one I I have I think it's from the queen
GT first and then we should do so
because if you should do two there is
true G3
so I think we g38g or UNF the bishop
little limiting
okay maybe better because then I just
deflect the bishop as well
yeah Queen F3 Bishop of three Bishop yes
that's the one perfect yeah we know
three was okay yeah
I guess Bishop D2
King A5 Rook A3 chip
unfortunately Bishop D2 doesn't work
because of work to G3 ah G3 so Queen F3
first yes okay Queen of the reverse yeah
perfect
nope
it's not made not quite it is a queen ah
oh it's a queen move
oh Queen after yeah it's Queen F3
uh yes exactly
foreign
[Music]
land of fjords Majestic mountains Cliffs
and waterfalls
in addition to studying geography Norway
is home to the greatest chess player who
has ever lived Magnus Carlson
since 2013 Norway has also hosted one of
the strongest chess super tournaments in
the world and it is one for which Magnus
has claimed the top prize in the last
four years
can anyone stop him
this time he'll meet one of his toughest
Challenges ever at his home tournament
with nine Rivals all hungry to beat the
best
from Carlson's fiercest online rival
today in their first classical
over-the-board battle in nearly four
years Hikaru Nakamura
to the young star Carlson once
hand-picked as his most worthy
Championship opponent alireza farouza
two more young stars are trying to
follow in his footsteps lodibeck Abdul
sotorov and kukesh domaraju
two established stars have already won a
Super tournament in 2023 Anish giri and
Fabiano caruana
two more long-time Headliners seek to
take their next turn Atop A major
tournament Wesley so and shakriya mamat
yarov
finally Carlson's Countryman and friend
ariantari rounds out the field who will
come out on top will Carlson run the
table yet again or will someone else
usurp the throne this is Norway chess
hello and welcome back and we are
Brewing up nicely for some chess
excitement and for those viewers who've
just joined us I am your host
International Mercy Ivanka houska and
it's a great pleasure being here in the
studio calling all the action alongside
the Magnificent Grand Masters Judith
poga and David Howell and it's been a
cagey start so far and it's looking like
for the first time there might be five
armageddon's on the cards
it's possible yeah indeed
[Laughter]
and that's the thing it's no boring
games at all it's just feels like
everyone's playing equally well at this
point everyone's warmed up it's the
second half of the tournament and
even when we think some imbalances are
existing in the position it feels like
uh their opponents are having all the
answers but of course it's still early
in the round we could still see some
surprises in the time scrambles and okay
where do we think the drawers are most
likely to happen in the near future
I have a suspicion that the game between
Shaq Mahmoud jarov and Wesley so could
be fizzling out
quite soon but I just feel that this is
because there's so much Dynamic
potential with the queens and Rooks on
the board that they will have to
initiate those trades to keep the game
alive
yeah let's jump in there as Wesley so is
pondering over his move we mentioned
earlier that night the White Knight was
likely to take the black Bishop at some
point black has clarified the situation
on the queen side with the past C Pawn
so if the Queen's ever come off a draw
very likely if the Rooks come off a draw
very likely and okay can this game
continue I'm looking at moves like Queen
to B1 maybe I'm not sure what it does
just to hint at some checks from behind
who's playing for the win
if anyone well fimby one I like uh
pretty much I think it's a very nice
idea but somehow I have the feeling that
mommy jarov is not thinking about the
draw right now he really wants to get
somehow in some way or another capture
the pawn on C4 after exchanging the
Queens because actually there are some
funny ideas here for example Rook C2
would be something to think of but that
would be a blunder because Rook d8 check
and black cannot go to H7 because Queen
C2 goes with the check black has to go
King F7 and that seems to be extremely
dangerous Rook Queen D7 Rooks G8 and
it's mate but there is another option
for example if black would be pushing C3
with similar idea then also rook d8 and
then Queen D3 check would be there so
there are some funny things going on and
the black king is much more vulnerable I
believe than than the white one and
maybe white wants to play King G3 and
start the journey so to H4 H5 one day if
white gets very romantic there or even
after Rook D4 because it just it was
just played two moves ago or one move
ago maybe Rick wants to go relocate
itself to G4 and make pressure there
yeah you're talking me into loving
weights position Judah
suddenly it sounds so logical once she's
gonna win this game and I just want to
thank you also for mentioning the king
walk because that I love King did cross
my mind
yeah it's one of the most beautiful
romantic things in chess because it's so
unexpected the king walk happens so
rarely in one's career that you can
advance with your king with Queen still
remaining so yeah I am I'm very
attracted to Queen We want just to kind
of cover this long diagonal and uh just
hoping that the black king can park
itself on H7
find a safe haven there but maybe
there's choices maybe there are
alternatives
something I've noticed David you're an
expert at spoiling the fun
it could be one of the King on H7
there's no trouble whatsoever yeah
actually when I did this adjustable
course with Magnus he in the
introduction he was like okay beloved
commentator but hated opponent because
that's all I try to do I don't even
think about my own plans I just want to
stop the opponents and that's no fun for
anyone but uh Queen V1 covering this
diagonal
yeah if but then again you do have to
consider rook and G4 as you said Judith
suddenly some counter play that maybe
tactics in the air yeah but maybe after
Queen B1 if we we can look look at that
move Queen B1 let's say G4 but I'm
afraid that it's not going anywhere for
white because maybe black can even play
C3 because if white takes on H6 for
example would be a mistake because Rook
H1 and queen E1 is there
and uh yeah that would be a trouble
no good king walk here because you've
been skewered so yeah maybe uh after
Queen B1 what else could white try uh is
there a threat because sometimes you can
get greedy and go Pawn hunting I'm not
sure if that's one of these cases maybe
the C Pawn just too strong here too
quick
what about playing Rook F4
and what's the idea if I the idea is to
go Quinn the eight and Rook f8
okay someone's meeting someone and
eventually I can take my King tour
okay give a check I'm not sure because
you're not going to give a check on E1
you can give a check GT6
wow but where's your where's your next
track
but the problem is King H4 you go Queen
G5 and you win the game oh
check small problem
one move and you're just in time to
promote your opponent's black
hmm yeah so in the position like this
instead of King H4 white I guess would
just retreat with the King
and I gave you another idea after Queen
B1 what if I go Rook E4
okay Queen B1 rookie for yeah nice
cutting I took everything you know
because you cannot give a check on G6
nor on E1 ah clever but maybe you need
the Rook to attack me
it comes later but do I need my queen
better right now I think
Queen check no Queen D7
oh porn hunting but uh you can defend
this right
or queen D6 maybe Queen D6 was aha and
then your idea is to go Rook to G4 Now
26 and then when you're going to play
Queen A2 or queen B3 then did these
three Square will be important
my other question is can I just ignore
your attacks you want to ignore my
attack
0.7 like more
because then you can line up with Rook
G4 but don't worry let's take this spawn
on E6 I'll give it to you okay C2 we
take on E6 we take bones yeah that's
well not stop us but dude if the City
Port is terrifying me what's the problem
with it's just a queen
C8 check I have to move winner five jack
okay I will Retreat and I go Rook the E4
Rook A4 Rook A4 okay
G4 is not working
well I may even play E6 that would be
too much WoW 6 E7 check and apparently
this isn't working but let's be
exaggerating let's check it out why it's
one move away from uh promotion but
anyone we need one oh Queenie one is the
cold-blooded approach the cold-blooded
killer but now White's winning G4
and White's doing the check mating
we found a way
coming soon to a chess Arena near you
this position
and that's quite wonderful actually
maybe we wrote it off too soon
competitors Gus this one's still full of
life if the players want to fight it out
and mama jarov is playing with the white
pieces yeah true it doubles the chance
that something will happen
and what about the clock situation
though you know both players I mean mama
jar off is 24 minutes Wesley 20 minutes
does that Inspire them to kind of
continue the game
I have a feeling Wesley would love to
get out of this game with the draw just
the way it's been going it's always
black been reacting on the back foot uh
kind of having to find the accurate
moves to survive I think you're right
dude it's my major if he wants to press
maybe on the board on the clock and at
least set a few problems if possible uh
already Queen B1 I mean it's the first
move that came to my mind but maybe
there are other more forcing ways
creepy one okay on the board on the
board and now let's see
what Shaq has in store for us
yeah I think either he'll choose a move
like rookie 4 where it's kind of really
fighting white wasn't risking anything
there there was always for petrol check
as you showed
um yeah either he'll go for something
like that and we'll see fire or
yeah there must be a way to lock it down
as well to force the draw immediately
but not his style
Shack right now
I want to see rookie for I want to see a
king much I want to see something I have
a question what if I go between A5
let's jump in Queen A5
you have a an A5 are you gonna give a
check and rookie won a queen E1
simplification right
that's a very Wesley type of thing to do
maybe check forcing the Queen's off and
yeah if you could win the C4 Pawn
without dropping E5 great winning
chances but here E5 is just falling
absolutely
so this would force the draw that makes
me think that actually maybe this is a
threat Rook H1 or at least in terms of
drawing Rook H1 followed by Queen E1
check
so the only way to prevent that is to
kind of block with your Rook or maybe
step forward first with your king
but I think it takes nerves or steel to
go rookie four and when the pawn goes C3
you just go it's the E Pawn I want
yeah enough still but yeah oh yeah oh D6
yeah but the thing here is just the
point that here C2 okay we showed a line
that was winning for black then winning
for white and turned around but at the
very minimum white can always force a
draw here if you really need to so you
might as well go down this line not risk
anything scare the opponent and
can bailout if necessary that is true
yeah the top players they love having
that safety net if possible at the same
time they don't like it when the pawns
are on C2 I don't think anybody likes it
when the ports are running like this
okay can we change to other game because
there are so many actions happening
shall we revisit the game between
orientare and Magnus Carlson because we
kind of mentioned the word
simplification here and some
simplifications simplifications have
happened
but I'm not really sure I do feel that
Magnus
can do his usual of working some magic
and extracting a victory from a position
which is objectively equal and the
reason I'm saying this is because I'm a
bit worried about Ariana's Pawn
structure there on the king side
yeah there's a few holes around the
white king I'm looking at the G3 Square
the White H Pawn lacks protection with
Queens off the board you would feel very
confident about drawing this one but I'm
also having flashbacks because I had
this exact material configuration
against Magnus uh just a few months ago
except I had my Pawn back on F2 and I
managed to draw that one uh it was
actually a pawns instead of B pawns but
everything else pretty much the same
identical and that one I drew
confidently but with a Pawn on F3 it's a
totally different board game shooter
well if you can jump into what are the
options for black I would suggest
strongly to play Rook A4 for black
immediately attacking the H4 pawn and
you're absolutely right David that
having the phone on F3 it gives a
completely different touch to the game
because G3 protecting the H4 is not
possible and I'm even thinking about
black exchanging the Queen's time to
time maybe if black can just exchange
the queen have the Rook on B4 it could
be some unpleasant threat on both and to
protect the H Earth attack the H4 yeah
for example Queen D4
between G3 is stronger between C5 first
and queen F2 yeah whoops this is one of
the pitfalls that could happen to White
due to the weakness on the dark squares
that we pointed out attacking this pawn
and attacking The Rook at the same time
right now Magnus is thinking what are
the strategies he can come up with
because he's going down in time and he
has 8 min minutes behind on clock he has
only his 15 minutes
so he must decide what he's going to be
doing in the next moves yeah just to
show you other point you that
um let's say let's just make a couple of
random moves but if the Queens do uh
come off the board uh this position
still unpleasant especially if the black
king activates the F6 and especially if
you get one more move and put the Rook
on B4 as you mentioned maybe here white
is able to save the day with a move like
Rook E4 but
um G3 and Rook B4 rookie two and you're
kind of holding it
yep just about still not fun but at
least solid for white uh so yeah Magnus
in the current position in the game
lots of tempting options I've got to say
you don't need to rush necessarily with
a rook A4 but I like it just asking
immediate questions of this white H Pawn
yeah I'm also looking at moves like King
H7 just get slightly safer just that's a
nice move waiting oh waiting your
opponent to decide what is his plan how
does he want to recover rookie 4 and
controlling the Force rank for example
but then the rookie one is possible
so but would you have time to tuck your
king into the corner because we saw
earlier some lines where white plays the
desired Queen F6 and relies very and
black relies very much on this tactical
ideas
yeah maybe there's uh maybe some urgency
yeah it does feel like Rook A4 is a very
Magnus type of move just probing just
asking a question well the clock times
though actually in ariane's favor Magnus
10 minutes down almost on the clock
could that be relevant it feels like
Magnus needs to put the pressure on here
and now and with 10 minutes to go before
they get increment 14 minutes isn't the
most we saw it against Anish just one
careless move and suddenly it was pretty
much equal and the game fizzled out
we saw swords and actually other games
for Magnus this tournament
if it's slower than usual
it is slower than usual and as always
I'm going to remind everyone of the time
control because it's very unique to
Norway chess once the players reach move
40 they will not be getting any added
time it will just be a simply a 10
second increment per move so they will
not get that time to work at all the
complexities of their position they will
just have to play on Instinct basically
and I just want to point out the rookie
four move from mamajarov is on the board
due that you predicted it you are a
prophetrius I was playing with him quite
a few times in my career he's looking
for chances and creating chances how did
those games go I just imagine fire on
the board oh we had the long great fight
the first game I played against him it
was very unfortunate for him but at the
time the Azerbaijan team was a real
Teenage Fantastic Team it was very
similar to the Indian two team which
they played with in Chennai they were
like incredible lineup with rajapov and
those top guys 15 16 years old and he
played open
uh Ryan Lopez and he just walked into my
home preparation you know he he actually
told me about that game he said before
that game he was really old school and
he was like I'm not going to use the
computers I don't need a computer I just
need to use this thing and I will use
books and he will literally log loads of
books with him to tournaments and to
work or whatever and so he prepared for
you using a book
and you just wiped him off the board and
after that he goes okay I understand
I will never use a book again
20 years later he's still playing the
open Spanish repertoire and he knows
what to do up to move 30. yeah yeah
actually it was a fun game with the way
the way I won but it was yeah I'm sure
it was memorable for him too from the
other end he owes you adapter I think
the amount he learned from that one and
okay we see some moves between those two
still level but uh okay my major are
fighting for the win okay that game is
actually getting spicy uh could we see a
result there any moment we also see
another game between gukesh and giri
that has simplified right down to the
last few pieces pawns yes and it's very
interesting because if you think about
it if black could exchange the Knight
give up the night for the B Pawn that's
a draw because the wrong color Corner we
have but it's a challenge how can Black
manage that one
yeah you need the king in the corner
over there on A8 and you need to give up
the Black Knight for the people it's not
so simple no but I would be surprised if
it's if it's too difficult to reach that
yeah the problem is the g-pawn is such a
distraction it costs white at least
three moves to go and win it with the
white King by which time the black king
is uh already over on the queen side and
the Black Knight will have gained some
Tempe in the process as well
interesting actually
um so now that the position has less
than seven pieces on the board chess has
been solved I hate to break it to Oyo
and we have something called a table
base where you can just simply check up
and look at all the moves possible and
it will tell you whether it's a win loss
or Draw and here it says draw
the only thing that it says white could
lose
if Wyatt puts the king and the bishop in
an unfortunate configuration so so for
instance if you step the king to C3
that would not be good news because the
night will come to E4 check okay don't
walk into any note Forks don't
accidentally block your Bishop's
protection of G1 and uh it should be a
draw but yeah I wonder how narrow the
path is for example let's just show A
variation Judith uh let's say the white
king drops back to E2 this is one this
one actually it's a draw immediately
because of Knight E4 and Knight C3 yeah
94 just to point out that black only has
six moves that draw six moves is enough
as long as you walk the king in this
direction it's a draw as well but 94 as
you mentioned and Knight to C3 check and
you win this Pawn because the white
Bishop cannot take the Knight due to
promotion but maybe let's try and show
another instructor variation let's say
94 doesn't happen let's say white is
given the time to okay the bars are
moving still a draw uh let's say white
is given the time to go and take the
spawn unfortunately
sooner or later Knight D2 is probably
not the right one Knight C3 C3 I would
go yep just something like this yeah
Knight C3 and if they go A4 oh yes yeah
but the white would not go away four he
would go A3 only I know it's just trying
to show the point that the king can run
into the corner and uh whoops not move
like a knight uh the king could uh move
into the A8 and sit there forever with a
draw but A3 as you say Judith but I
think black would be chasing the pawn by
playing Knight B1
after A3 and after A4 you chase the pawn
again
probably with Knight C3 and after A5 you
go King C6 yeah or am I doing something
wrong here I think you're fine here A6
maybe five and nine oh oh I have blunted
oh have I
still looks like a draw to me
all the Knight needs to do is somehow
give itself up for this pawn and it will
be a draw no probably I went wrong with
Knight C3 King C6 first and after that
to play Knight C3 to reach out to B5
yeah right instead of Knight C3 yeah to
go there yeah either way black is about
to draw this game uh as long as he finds
the Right Moves with his Knight and his
King and uh I would like to dash to the
Hikaru game because alireza has done
just done a very Nifty night maneuver
check this out these nights they went
Knight F3 went Knight H2 Knight F1
up the board I went on an odyssey
okay and uh yeah let's have a look at
how it went okay so this is the current
position it's Bishops against Knights I
mentioned that the black Bishop wanted
to reach D6 I'm very happy if I'm uh
Hikaru here and uh let's backtrack a few
moves you mentioned the night maneuver
Ivanka take a look at the journey right
there you go that's where it originally
started okay okay so it started on F3
dominated by this F6 Pawn Yeah and then
it went
H2 it continued yeah Queen B8 attacking
the Knight
the Knight continued around and it sits
on E3
is it great though on E3 this night but
look what's happened it went he went
there just to go Knight to G4 in order
to annoy Edge six black says no and
is there with this Knight on E3 good
decision bad decision but it's funny
because the other night was on E3 before
yeah I was confused by the position it's
like what is this night doing why is it
not already on C5 I guess he wants to
put pressure on this Apon keeping black
honest over here
uh the problem is anytime you attack
this apron for example with the White
Queen firstly it's not clear whether
it's attacked secondly the black queen
can always defend uh she defends the
pawn she hits White's Pawn in the center
as well somehow I have the feeling that
black got a relief
by exchanging one Rook from the board it
favors black yeah I think massively and
H5 this is the game position
no infiltration now from the white Rook
these Bishops are so good at covering
all the empty uh squares on the e-file
suddenly this Pawn nicely protected
I think alireza just maybe missed an
opportunity yeah
but fair play to Hikaru kind of
maneuvering really nicely as black and
talking about maneuveras and King safety
can we Dash over to the abdusator of
Fabiana Carolina game because white has
just played H2 H4 and we have to kind of
look at that because I don't know what
is happening
yeah this game suddenly got wild how did
this happen it was so locked up so
blocked and yeah right played G3 right
yeah that means Abdus tour of is the one
fighting for the win
trying to create chances everything is
just livening up as well you know
simultaneously we jinxed it we said five
drawers five armageddon's and suddenly
the players it's as if they heard us
they perked up and were like no no more
fighting chess for you the only thing
I'm afraid of that the Armageddon games
will be at the same time
because they're all of the five games
they're still playing and we are deeply
into the fourth hour yeah and I actually
think we're about to see a result we'll
go into detail here but we're about to
see a result between managerov and
Wesley so the King march did happen
White's King is sitting on the edge of
the board but that one's about to finish
any second now with a repetition
I think we'll see a handshake
any second we see the moves whites just
giving the black king a bunch of checks
black king moving
and there we go handshake we have our
first result
yes and this match it did finish in a
draw and we will see an Armageddon being
played out between Shaq mamajarov and
Wesley so in approximately 20 minutes
but they entertained us at the end right
with the queen and the rook and a
potential King march but in the end it
was just very accurately yeah very
accurate play uh White's King did end up
on H4 as we predicted but no wait to
Checkmate it and we see the players
smiling they were entertained by that
battle we were entertained by that
battle but all ends peacefully
okay should we head back to that Abdus
tour of game yes let's see what's
happening because there is some exposure
King is very much in the corner what can
happen to white or to Black
yeah I think the first question is can a
plaque get greedy here I don't think you
can but uh White has just offered up a
pawn and the time is ticking
okay 12 minutes against 14 we mentioned
actually the track record between these
two when things get crazy Abdus tour of
has had the upper hand just in recent
weeks against Fabi in Rapid chess so
maybe that will uh haunt Fabi H4 on the
board to take or not to take Judah is
that too much
well well well I don't know how Brave
black can be
can black take on H4 and after that
white is jumping with the Knight to H5
King G6 but then the Knight seems to be
trapped
I think we have to jump in and show some
lines H4 it was abdisotarov who's
initiated all of this uh kind of mutual
attacking play pontex Pawn I'm expecting
to see the evaluation bar react no it
doesn't
night check as you mentioned through
that the what uh the black king steps
forward and the Knight is simply will be
captured and that night is gone it's
like mirroring Mama Jarvis King here
just the King march on H5 but it's safe
the Black Knight will ride to itself G5
on Queen G2 yeah
Queen G2 not G5 as you mentioned just
safe as houses this black king
so what does uh no deal work has in mind
after H4 if black captures it is it
possible that he just wants to go back
with the
Queen h8
okay h8 was played instead Queen h8
played
um wow
which is a logical reaction that you
don't want to open up your king you want
to have a contour attack you want to
have safety for your own King yeah just
to point out apparently in this position
the only move to keep the balance for
white is now back to F1
which is not easy to spot I guess the
idea is to come to E3 and try to trap
this black Rook
difficult move there but in the end as
you say to it Queen h8 was fabby's
Choice pinning and forcing the move H5
locking down the king's side it's the
safer choice I believe
he has not much time and we know it from
him he said it that the time can be very
tricky when it gets down because that's
all what they have only after move 40
from this move right from this move on
they get an extra 10 seconds
small consolation 10 seconds in a crazy
position like this yeah and I'm
wondering what the black wants to do is
he going to be going G4 at some point or
uh
G4 makes a lot of sense you know you
have to start destabilizing the white
king at the same time you're not so
happy to open up around the orcing right
because after G4 maybe F takes G4 and if
Bishop G4 Rook G1 and the other king is
also very much exposed I was thinking
all it's a possibility to go Knight G5
because the bishop on E6 is the great
defensive piece although although you
know it does invite complications
as well with the queen diving into D6
Anything Can Happen yeah process of
elimination as well fabi's Rook is
totally kind of immobilized right now
it's stuck as black this Black Knight is
stuck for now just preventing the White
Queen from coming in black Bishop
perfectly placed so it's either
feels like a queen move I'm not sure
where Queen C8 for example or G4 unless
black feels he has time to kind of
Shuffle with King H7 first uh to kind of
prepare G4 for later Queen H7
on the board is he really hinting at F5
maybe or maybe preparing G4 if this
white E4 Pawn is weak
that's possible that he wants to go G4
with an idea to after G after HG for
Rook takes E4 sacrificing The Exchange
and then the white square Bishop can be
extremely powerful spicing it off with
the Knight coming to G5 and that can be
very dangerous for white
yeah so it really can't move there from
Fabi I like it I've got to say it would
not have been on my radar Queen H7 but
the light squares is where it's going to
happen and maybe this is just a path
into the wipe Camp later
okay after sotorov if we put ourselves
in his shoes how to improve White's
position this time well it's very
important for black that he covers all
the important squares on the D line D5
D6 D7 d8 there is no entry for white so
which means also that the Black Knight
cannot move because then the D6 and d8
important squares would be open for
entry for white but I think white has to
deal with the this G4 idea so he has to
make some prophylactical moves Rook G1
seems to be a logical idea for me
okay you will not break through on this
side of the board without severe risk
but uh
but you still do it anyhow right
Maybe
the type of move that you kind of play
and you hope your opponent can't do it
it's as if you're saying okay no you
cannot walk through the store and your
opponent just walks through the door
anyway exactly Richie one G4 Rook even
can be a prophylactico move as well
defending the E4 Pawn so after f after
G4 white can capture on G4
okay I'm gonna put you back on the spot
uh still black you said to Black's
position 20 moves ago
um I'm okay with black
it's okay black has maybe more more
some more tactics in mind
feels like the stakes are higher for
white I'm not sure so sure about what ft
satora's done just kind of opening up
the king side it feels like the white
king could really Rue uh all of these
open lines open diagonals whereas the
black king for now looks pretty
comfortable pretty cozy on G7
but but yeah okay okay I was just gonna
ask that question how dangerous is this
G4 if you just accept everything and he
just says you know what I'm just going
to step forward with the King
and so what's the idea after G4
no idea
[Laughter]
call a deal with no ice no idea yeah G4
he's got to play it right Fabi he wants
to win well well I don't know that seems
to be very promising continuation right
now
should we jump in and just investigate
What's Happening Here G4
it's looking likely fabi's in an
ambitious mood we know that this
tournament
okay how to replay with white
would white want to go maybe F4
but also rookie for
yeah just to put your line on the board
now we give up material but we break
through to that white king no that was
not my idea to take on e4 somehow I
thought maybe I have some other idea H6
or something and
yeah I think this one looks good for
black right to sacrifice
at least if the sacrifice is accepted as
true Dimensions because after H6 what do
you take with I wanted Knight originally
but
I have a feeling you might come in and
behind somehow
looks a bit scary for the black king
it's another 86 26 yeah maybe yes nicer
path in it's another game it's like
who's chick mating who yeah the thing is
maybe I'm not threatening with much
maybe just it takes porn
but then check in Knight D4 ah wait my
Rook is hanging this time yeah so you
forced me onto a diagonal where you've
blocked the connection between the king
and rook and you take
and game over
okay this is gonna really spice up if
Abby does decide to play G4 a move like
F4 is just going to be so chaotic this
is I think what the players must be
calculating right because uh just to
show as well if F takes G4 it feels a
bit wrong Knight G5 Could Happen winning
this Pawn again I think you just take on
e4
yeah take the spawn
it could be similar with H6 but crazy
lines ahead
Fabby if he doesn't want to play G4 if
he doesn't want to kind of press uh the
red button and just explode it open what
does he do instead
just wait Queen back to h8
well this is a very serious moment
because it's not so easy just to make a
move because sometimes Knight F1 Knight
E3 is a threat so now I think white
wants to go Rook H1 defend the pawn on
H5 also maybe H6 push H6 sacrificing it
but also keep in mind that root Knight
f-193 can trap denied The Rook
and we saw in the camera that app this
is sort of stretching if it's the type
of position where you can get excited
for both sides and wow seven minutes for
Fabi that's going to be a tactical
Minefield we know he's good at
calculation but G4 F4 just who knows
what's happening there
very complicated game and there are a
lot of calculation has to be done though
Fabiano is one of the best calculator
out there in the world yeah for sure
and okay should we pause this one until
Favi makes a decision
we have a couple of games we could go to
go cash against Gary still looks drawn
but I think it's a draw immediately by
the way okay should we go there
um I think it's a good time to take a
break because we are gonna need to catch
our breath because things are heating up
very very nicely so see you in a few
minutes
thank you
[Music]
foreign
excitement continues and before the
Armageddon game between Shakura
mamajarov and Wesley so begins let's
take a look at the bird's eye view and
dive in into all the action
so first up between arientari and Magnus
Carlson what are we thinking it's
looking good for the Norwegian number
one it's looking good for one of the
Norwegians and it does feel like Magnus
has established full domination Judith
uh he's got his pieces on perfect
squares the question is is there a
breakthrough well this is going to be
the question but Magnus is uh with his
magic hand he's usually doing it the way
that the opponent will run out of time
though it's him right now who went down
under four minutes and he has only three
minutes while uh tari has nine minutes
but still he has a very safe position
and he's going to be maneuvering
somewhere that he wants to force the
opponent to make mistake but definitely
he's having the upper hand and uh the
game between gukash and Anish giri looks
to me like it's just a draw yeah I
expect this game to finish any moment
now black is about to promote uh and
she's going to make a new queen that
will cost white his bishop and White's
two pawns the uh Runners there can be
easily blocked by the black king white
is just one or two moves too slow here
not in time to promote this game will
end peacefully and the situation doesn't
look so clear-cut in the game between
alireza farouza and hikara Nakamura a
lot of tension there they're absolutely
some crazy things happening I must say
because this H4 H5 set that by definite
about that that it does favor Black and
now black has to make a decision whether
is he going to capture the Knight and
the change the pawn structure setting
and then later on from the queen from C8
he's going going to jump into the white
scam so there I think Nakamura suddenly
has some opportunities or at least it's
going to be shaken off completely and
white has only four minutes while Hikaru
has almost doubled the time the clock is
always an important factor when it
happens now it becomes very serious part
of the game yeah absolutely and finally
we were discussing the very exciting
game between nordeback abdisoturf and
Fabiano caruana
we were kind of curious why he hadn't
pushed that pawn on the king side to uh
early on but he's done it now
yeah that one has opened up it feels
like uh caruanas he's founded really
tricky maneuver white is temporarily
upon up but Abdul satorov has some big
questions to answer on the light squares
meanwhile this Armageddon game ready to
start manager with the white pieces
predictions
he made such a good game yesterday and
he was pressing all the way today in the
classical game I see that the Wesley was
already before the move started first
move started he's dense and very focused
I think
yes and the game starts as a symmetrical
English opening uh as signified by white
and black both pushing the C pawns as
early as move one and two and okay it's
going to continue to be symmetrical both
sides playing pretty much copycatchers
Wesley Rock Solid and mamajarov has to
work his magic he's gone for something
similar before this tournament where he
pushed the H Pawn there we go against
gokash he played and it did not it
turned out to be very good in the
opening and he had a huge Advantage but
later on something went wrong yeah and
well Wesley is known to be very solid
player and so he steps forward with his
H Pawn one square getting ready to meet
any advances and Shaq choosing the whole
board now switching to play on the queen
side
yep shot getting ready to push pawns
forward that last Rook Shuffle designed
to play B4 black has to decide what to
do and Wing play counted in the center
we've seen that theme before already
today again very logical from Wesley so
a Trader Pawns in the center and Wesley
what is he gonna do right now
he's going to take with the pawn black
has a beautiful structure there but
manager of continuing their strategy
playing on the wings
I like it for black so far
because last move attacking a white Rook
with the bishop
yeah nice play by Wesley fast play by
Wesley most importantly in this
Armageddon but still a three minute
difference between the two The Rook does
not look good on B2 in the the Knight is
in the pen from the Vian Chateau Bishop
on G7 so it looks very promising for
black at first sight
yes but that's one of the things about
mama jarov he likes to play these
unconventional positions he has the
confidence as well to do this and
somehow other he banks on his attacking
skills to carry him through these
dubious stages of the game well it is
dubious because after C4 it looks like
very dangerous for white but he runs he
takes B4
ah capture of upon that it would look
like extreme provocation from mamajara
but Wesley choosing a simpler approach
the question is are either side gonna
Castle their King to safety wow okay
breaking news a draw between alireza
farrugia and Hikaru Nakamura
surprise there looked like that game was
just heating up but both players will
take their chances in the Armageddon but
uh let's stick with this game for now
why tonight has entered the black half
on C5 nice Outpost there but feels again
like black is so active and centralized
dude yeah but I've liked it two moves
earlier much better from the black side
now the Knight is very active on C5
I think black is going to be capturing
the V4 so mamajaro is sacrificing a pawn
but he's going to have some activity for
sure
yep activity will be the name of the
game eight minutes against five minutes
how does mamajarov Ensure maximum
compensation for the pawn that he's
about to drop on the queen side
does he just Castle does he push the H
Pawn this is Mama drop we see a question
mark attached to Wesley so's last move
so maybe not the best worsening his
position but very logical he's going
after this week before Pawn both Knights
targeting it right now
move suggestions I'm struggling I've got
to say I would just castle and postpone
the inevitable well I think sometimes H5
can be also be considered but now
foreign
not yet
E4 looks like a fork but it will be
captured on passant yes and it would
open up blacks dark Square some Knight
E1 can be an idea to open up the
diagonal for the G2 Bishop but there is
a pawn hanging there on B4 and the shack
well he decides to first of all Probe on
the king side
and then play your and the E4 is there
yeah I blundered a bit but actually the
sacrifice seems to be interesting
yeah interesting is uh the right word
here Bishop takes Rook looks like it
wins material but after the white Bishop
recaptures white will be the one owning
all of the dart squares and if White's
bishop ever ends up on this diagonal
lines up with the queen that would
likely end in Checkmate so I don't think
I would be greedy it's not Wesley's
style here to take the material and
suffer but then again threats the white
Rook threatening to come to D2 the white
Pawn threatening to step forward to E4
with a fork well we shouldn't forget
that it's Armageddon game black needs to
make it only a draw so that's why also
why this risking a lot and goes out
sacrificing material and plays so
interestingly so black has to decide
make decisions which is not so simple at
this point and uh Wesley not actually
taking the rook and instead grabbing the
pawn this is a good decision when you're
facing chakra mamajov you have to play
with your Tactical a game
I think a great decision to keep the
dark Squad Bishop the white Rook less
important here as long as Black's King
has a bishop for a friend it will not
get checkmated but meanwhile while
tactics a trade of knights in a really
unique way there and now it's the Black
Knight in the center that's attacked
it's also the black rook in the corner
white slight squared Bishop
maybe hitting it can capture it in some
circumstances it's like uh basically the
same offer that mamajarov gave to Wesley
Wesley's offering it back well I would
think Knight C2 is The Logical
continuation so black is
counter-attacking the to the white Rook
and it's on the board it is on the board
oh I'm very tense position and there you
see Shaq just simply capture the pawn
but now we are going into an end game
and I think white will start beginning
to regret the fact that his Bishop is
all the way on C1
yeah the black Brooks will try to
infiltrate and win this trapped piece
suddenly yeah Queens off the board
Wesley will be breathing a sigh of
relief it feels like he's closer to
safety still four minutes on the clock
should be sufficient uh the players get
that one second increment later and Mara
jar of Rook D5 nice way to trade but on
his own terms a rook trade will land a
white Bishop in the center of the board
well that will be would be very
appealing for a white to have a bishop
on D5 but I think that black is not
going to capture it probably Bishop G4
for example seems to be interesting with
an idea of Knight E1 in the later stage
only a little bit thinking about
capturing the pawn on H5
yeah really nice movement I think that's
the fourth or fifth time Judy you've
mentioned a black knight ending up on E1
d1c1 yeah yeah
really nice Vision there and okay Mama
drive has to do something he tries to
put his Rook on the seventh rank yeah
and your move on the board we'll check
on F3 is incoming but the problem is
white is in a must-win situation
any hope
there's no hope there is always hope no
God Bishop E4 yeah any hope rests with
his light squared Bishop I was going to
say and you have to keep that one alive
as long as you do you have chances
Black's night is a bit stranded he needs
to hop back into the game sooner or
later most likely via F3 but it's a
provocation what about F5 is white going
to play 96 in that case
that's why Bishop F3 yeah nice move
because you cannot trade Bishop because
the knights will come to F3 and give a
check and the protection of the Rook is
gone
you have to decide what to do with this
white rook in the center of the board I
think white has no other choice than
take it on the eight and then capture on
F3 King G2 at the same time G4 G4
checkmating ideas with getting the route
down to D1 and G1 oh I'm really not
liking this for shark Bishop F3 is very
powerful move
great move by Wesley and he's forced
Shaq to think look at this head in hands
now mama jarov he knows that the white
king is not entirely safe
I don't know if he can get away with
trading Rooks and okay there we go again
allowing the root trade but on his terms
if the Rooks disappear at least black
cannot break through yet with his heavy
pieces is there some Brook C8 Rook C8 is
coming
yeah skewer hitting the Knight hitting
the bishop behind it really strong move
there can white simply guard that night
you should pay three there we go C5 is
not possible to rook d8 and Wesley
immediately responding by retreating the
bishop attacking the Knight
yeah attacking the Knight the bishop
behind it another pin this time
how do you defend against this not easy
anymore
why does the one fighting for survival
let alone the win yeah and still that
pawn on it H5 is up for grabs and whoa
we just saw the evaluation bar shoot up
in Black's favor yeah it took a while to
react at the computer but realizing that
this uh is just potentially deadly for
white here okay my major are trying to
counter attack feels a bit ambitious but
he's trying to break through on this F7
Square does it work
can you get greedy and then hide the
king I think the easiest is to capture
on D5 and Knight C2 well he has grabbed
it
and in other results anishikiri and
gokash they did draw so we will see two
more armageddon's
and right now in this game black is a
piece up Wesley grabbing that white
knight and looks like he's surviving
really nice move this could be the
killer blow that white Rook now forced
away from the seventh rank whereupon the
white Bishop would drop in manager of
has indeed resigned masterclass from
Wesley
yeah about a practical Choice he made
that he did not capture The Rook The
Exchange he did not take because he felt
that it can be dangerous he went to the
safe way and then he created the
opportunity for him there with Knight E1
and controlling the F3 square and
basically won the game and the match
absolutely
very impressive play from Wesley so and
that leaves two classical games
remaining and looking at the bird's eye
view it looks like in both games the
black pieces are in complete control
yeah where to go too first it looks like
Magnus Carlson has worked his endgame
magic and should have some Advantage but
uh the other game may be slightly more
fiery right now wow it's burning right
now it's under one minute for another
wreck and Fabiano has two minutes The
Rook is on G1 just about to give a check
on G7 but it seems to be that the king
is moving into the corner and there is
no more check while the white king can
be in huge danger right now the 90s
attack and also Rook C2 seems to be a
threat so this is a
saved and defended in one move with
Knight E3
but it seems very dangerous yeah really
dangerous but really nice move there
from Fabiano as well counter-attacking
the Black Brook was actually trapped the
White Knight about to take it but
suddenly the removal of White's H6 Pawn
means the white Rook is threatened and
the Black Knight is jumping forward with
some checks too it's so scary that black
king looks like it's about to get
checkmated but it is threatening to
escape by capturing the white Rook no
time to deliver any checks and why test
30 seconds
shortly not more than that yeah I mean
30 minutes on the clock to navigate your
way around this may uh this mess right
now nodded back in trouble
two pawns down as well maybe Rook G3 is
the only move
treating the white Rook
okay no he's taken the black Rook
instead okay big threat on the board of
uh the white playing Queen takes Knight
on H6
but of course this is something that
Fabi will be spotting
you have some crazy tactics here if
Black's King takes this Rook white has
ideas like giving a check with the white
Bishop on f8 I'm not sure whether that
works out but it certainly has to be
calculated uh so Fabi right now
hesitating he's got options he could
give a check first with the black queen
he doesn't need to commit uh going to F5
check for example
what will he play Queen H4 is also
another check option
and okay that position is wild but let's
dive into the Magnus game because take a
look at that time control both players
seconds left
oh Magnus is that 18 seconds and Ticking
down yeah 18 seconds against
29 seconds there and look at the white
king it's been the story of the round so
many King walks to the edge of the board
and who's checkmating who another
question is Magnus breaking through
he's going to give some checks with the
black queen from behind Ariane slides
across to C4 leaving his King undefended
I know and G5
wow played wow with 11 seconds left on
the clock and Magnus really taking all
the risks
yeah I love that tweet simultaneous
armageddon's uh just time scrambles in
the classical games Who's checkmating
Who and okay Arya now captures that pawn
but it allows the black Rook into the
game
surely this is a mistake well in C3
check there is some check options but
it's Black's move yes and Magnus six
seconds to work out the world
complications and he throws in a check
and oh yeah instantly
that's another track the white kid's
forced around look at that King on F4
King march today
mine is just getting away look at that
Queen H2 King G5 F6 King F5 Queen E5
would be made but F6 Rook takes F6
oh and Magnus make that move with one
second left on the clock he nearly
apologized and okay the check from the
black queen was blocked
oh white needs a counter punch now
otherwise it's over well now is the time
for Aryan to start checking he has 30
seconds left on the clock he can give
his own checks the White Queen has to
check that black king
what time
and there you see it
and the black king cannot hide from the
tracks maybe this is the problem for
Magnus check on D3
the only way to play for the win is to
trade off the Rooks and block with the
black Rook but that will not lead to
Victory
and how Magnus
sticking down to 14 seconds
this one should end in a repetition of
moves the black king will move the White
Queen will continue the dance by giving
checks
I don't think he can afford to play on
okay he does continue this game but what
is the upside here Rook takes Rook
guaranteed
we head to a queen end game but
black I don't think he's better here but
he wants to win so desperately
yeah he's
anything to win but some risk involved
the white king is so active that might
even help white now that the Rooks are
off the board yeah and uh take a look at
WISE pawns all protected
and so few pawns on the board and Ariane
actually his King is pretty safe no
trouble whatsoever but can he hold his
nerve he has 25 seconds left
one thing to watch out for are queen
trades that could go in either direction
you have to be really careful before
calculating any king of Portland games
here here king queen D4 is very powerful
centralized the queen queen h8 is a
threat animate in one B6 spawn is under
attack so black will have to make
Perpetual check unless but he has Queen
over here he can take the pawn but then
it's a Perpetual check with queen h8 and
queen d8
this game will end in a draw any moment
you called it Judith Queen takes pawn
and white can immediately Force the draw
check in the corner and there's no
Escape for that black king
the black king almost checkmated but uh
there we go it only has these two
squares and we'll see the position
repeat Magnus leaning back in his chair
disappointment he had this game under
control
and here we'll see the handshake
and it's a draw and they're Armageddon
kind of
[Laughter]
four armageddon's on the table this
round and uh oh Ariane breathing a big
sigh of relief you can't quite believe
it
yeah he was under heavy pressure from
Magnus
Magnus very annoyed these two are good
friends of course but In the Heat of
battle
yeah they both needed to take a second
there to kind of calm the nerves get
over what has just happened process it
and they'll be back at the board
fighting against each other very shortly
and uh talking about what's just
happened there will not be a fifth
Armageddon this round because Fabiana
caruana has defeated nordebec Abdul
sotorov to take three points
I mean we saw an order back there
struggling with his King wide open
perhaps we can take a recap of what
happened yep let's jump into that game
Fabiano in the lead and he extends that
lead with a really important win
bouncing back from yesterday's defeat
this uh we'll see in a moment is the
final position in the Fabiano game
winning with black as well really
important there but uh this was the
final position let's just recap from a
bit earlier on we saw total chaos and it
was this position where we left it after
Knight takes C4 winning the blackrook
Fabiana did indeed capture the white
rook and after a check deflecting away
the black king we saw a trade of pieces
and after King to G8 simply no checks
for weight and you either go into a
miserable Queen end game or you continue
gambling as abdusator of did keeping the
knights and Bishop on the board but
unfortunately the black king just too
safe and two pawns up for Fabiano he
finished it in really nice style and
this was the killer blue after F4 the
White Knight tried to jump so close to
getting to the black king but not close
enough not quick enough F3 check the
killer blue because after King takes
Pawn to F4 is a killer the White Knight
drops off with check next move beautiful
technique for Fabiano
absolutely it's so precise and for me a
little bit unexpected that he managed to
turn it around because it did look like
it was going to be a draw but you know
congratulations to Fabiano great
comeback and leading the competition
very comfortably now
how the tides have turned you know we're
talking yesterday what's this morning
about how the competition was wide open
maybe not anymore
yeah those players especially Hikaru in
the chasing pack they need to win the
Armageddon to have any chance to be
within touching distance of Fabiano now
well of course classical again Victory
it counts exactly the double as the
victory in Armageddon and this was a
very important victory for Fabiano for
the standings that's very clear and it
was a very nice way how he did it right
he was playing a close position and he
was playing on both sides and it was not
clear we were not sure whether would we
prefer playing it with the white side or
the black side so he was just sitting
there and looking for opportunities
taking
somehow inviting nadir back to make some
risky decisions another work of course
one of the most talented players
nowadays and uh yeah but uh one thing
that we are gonna see because we're
gonna be spoiled for excitement AR3
armageddon's let's have a look at the
Armageddon for format the players will
keep the same colors white will start
with 10 minutes black seven minutes and
one second added after move 40 and of
course the most important thing that
black gets draw odds white must win and
here we see the colorful alireza farouza
playing with the white pieces in a
must-win situation against Hikaru
Nakamura
and we expect a fruity game here from
alireza it's the Italian game at this
early stage white needs to win of course
and he's taking a big risk playing the
Italian against maybe the world leading
expert from the black side of these
positions meanwhile White's Bishop
pinning the Black Knight on G5 being
kicked back now that's good Bishop it
all revolves around that piece Hikaru
though I've seen him have this position
before so many times and often just
winning with it as black uh very
successful here interesting strategy
from alarisa and uh yeah what do you
think good opening choice
well it seems like a very good situation
for for Hikaru I think because it's a
very stable system before I was
expecting and G5 look at that of course
it's uh in the spirit of the position
but still when you need a draw and it
would give you a victory uh match
Victory you don't necessarily go for G5
in the earliest phase of the game
yeah I guess he just knows his openings
he trusts his openings I'm loving that
panda in the featured chat from our
producer but uh yeah right now I just
think Hikaru too experienced unless
ferrugia has something specific prepared
up his sleeve and look at the Black
Knight stepping out of the way the black
F pawns getting ready to come through
black H pawns getting ready to come
all the pawns running but white is going
to go D4 at some point is it already the
time
it might be flank attack met by a strike
in the center that would be very
thematic and just the fact that farooges
burned so much time on the clock he's
down to just a two minute time Advantage
now
it uh means warning bells for me
of course a sharp position and he loves
these types this type of fire on the
board so early days he needs to do
something now I think Judith just D4
just play go for it well the E4 right
now would be a pawn sacrifice at the
moment so Knight C4 was played probably
for a later stage to play D4 and Knight
E3 would be the plan right now I believe
but after H5 it's not possible because
H4 is just a threat immediately so
whether white will be playing H3 or H4
this is the question yeah
and I think they they tend to play H3
but the great thing for Hikaru or H4 on
the board and the great thing with forek
Hikaru is that he knows this position so
well he's seen it before he can just
make those moves at Tempo and look at
that he's just racing through this like
he's seen this a million times before
yeah and uh this could quite possibly
quite feasibly be his opening
preparation Hikaru he's coming around
with his Knight now to take this Pawn
from where it will put pressure on this
white Bishop that being said the white
King has a nice day Square on H2 later
id5 please oh sacrifice bang just take
this Pawn then recapture with the bishop
you give up material but you get to that
black king I think that would be great
but after Knight E5 maybe Knight F5 the
intermediate movies
is the good move in return well we see a
very fancy move because he's just
jettisoned his Pawn on F6 Knight takes
Pawn on the board
yeah throwing away the pawn but it was
doomed anyway uh interesting decision
there from farrugia and now what next it
feels like again white needs to open up
the center at some point this black
Bishop is so powerful it would make
sense to get off that diagonal for the
white king as well it also feels that
the Black Knight is going to relocate
itself to F5 to put pressure on the
bishop on G3
yeah lots of natural ideas here for
black and even if white objectively has
a decent position it's harder to come up
with ideas for white right now maybe
white wants to go Knight E3 to stop
Knight F5 as much as much as possible
so after Knight F5 there would have been
exchange on the on F5 we need two Knight
D4 and later on maybe the king moved to
H1 and F3 or F4 because Knight F5 comes
with a great power in this position and
he predicted it Judith Knight E3 on the
board instantly reacted with this
nitrate now Hikaru Nakamura and it's a
question of who this peace trade favors
blacks no longer got these big threats
with the Knight but then again
traits decent healthy Pawn structure
here Black's King not too not too uh in
too much danger here maybe bishop C2
also makes sense with white with an idea
to break out with D4 and exchange of the
Bishops but D4 is on the board and just
to mention the times I mean Hikaru has
really gained some time on the clock
because he has just under six minutes
and alireza who started with a three
minute Advantage is down to six minutes
and I said the three minute time deficit
is now down to around 30 seconds good
news for Hikaru super Speedy so far we
see the last move a question mark for
alireza farrugia here it is upon
sacrifice it does mean a mistake it made
his position worse as we see there in
the game review but this is Armageddon
he just needs to win he just needs a bit
of chaos and Hikaru takes the bait he
takes up the challenge and grabs the
pawn
let's see if the Rook on A1 will be
sacrificed by Knight C4 let's say
yeah that's an Armageddon type of move
just like in that clash between
manageriff and Wesley so taking this
Rook means that black gives up all the
dark squares and White's Queen will
replace it and on this nice long
diagonal long-term compensation you
could also be move the Rook but that is
a slower approach admitting that it was
attacked in the first place
and there we go
Rook C1 on the board he needs his Rook
but it's chased it's trapped now this
Rook you have to give up material if you
move forward then the other black Bishop
can jump in to D3 and Fork the two white
Rooks but is this wise especially when
Black's King is so open
I don't know if it's wise it's uh it's
critical at least it's either very good
here for black or it could backfire and
Hikaru tries to trap The Rook in another
way attacks it with a pawn instead okay
attack the bishop
yep surely he's going to swing The Rook
across towards the king side
or a cafe very likely here what else
simply
on the board
yeah this one I see the featured chat
imagine playing Hikaru in a Time
scramble this is going to be a time
scramble it already is five minutes
against five minutes
Hikaru I like his last move just full
control curling up into a ball
protecting the black king with his
pieces F3 yeah I was thinking about
removing the Defenders with Bishop C2
two Fireball moves here Bishop C2
F3 break open the other white Rook Jude
you're the attacker I defer to you here
F3 looks so tempting the only problem is
Bishop E5 is trapping my rogue but still
I would think fdhg4 I'm not sure how
good is that but the Rook can be in
trouble already
farrugia calculating please rookie one
neither of our moves
and Bishop E5 on the board
oh
how is farooja gonna handle this it's
getting intense yeah material is gone
that's for sure white is already two
points down his Rook was trapped so he
just Retreats his Knight yeah but the
problem is that black can capture the F4
and Knight E4 can show up on the board
which would be very nicely placed in the
center but will Hikaru have the guts to
remove such a fantastic piece as the
bishop and swap It For The Rook
I think it's too tempting some material
uh oh he doesn't he resists that the
Temptation here I was going to say some
material up is one thing but winning a
white Rook is another and queen to D7
he's just getting ready to now what
about Rook E5 thanks Rook F6 Queen D1
Rook G6
Rook takes Bishop it leads to a crazy
variation where we'll see black with two
Rooks against whites three minor pieces
he has to go for it I think that's a
great chance for white that's a
beautiful resource
yeah I don't know if a car has seen it
maybe only after he made the move
because to see it and evaluate it takes
a lot of time that's why farrugia has
paused now he's in the tank I think he
spotted it he's trying to weigh up the
pros and cons
spotted it
I think for sure both of them have look
at far Asia just leaning back there for
a second
is he gonna go for rookies he was not
moving for quite a few seconds and uh
and just waiting for it it's happening
on the board all of the minor pieces
disappearing white throws assistant in
between moves there suddenly blinking
you miss it the Queen's come off and
Hikaru shaking his head
yeah he's shaking his head but how good
is this piece in balance for white and
bearing in mind that he's very annoying
three pieces can't coordinate it to the
best ability just yet yeah the
evaluation bar shows to us that black
still has a good position but for Hikaru
it means he's lost all control he
doesn't know the evaluation and looks
like the white pieces are stable uh two
Bishops and a knight are a great
attacking Force if they can combine at
the same time Rook D4 and if black would
be able to capture the pawn on B4 or
somehow simplify it then it would be
Black's favor but they're so easy to
blunder with black and now after Rook D4
A3 will be the move white is not giving
up that pawn yeah yeah this is still
going to be a big fight now anything
could still happen he defends simply
with this Rook but this is inviting the
White Knight forward later at some point
yes I think A3 the quiet move
no F3 farooza breaking out I think he
felt that his dark Square Bishop didn't
have a future so he had to get it
working
okay and say car is just trying to
simplify trying to get as many pawns off
the board as possible now pushing
forward with C5 both sides were shaking
their heads a moment ago neither side
knows who's better it's such a wild
imbalanced position
Bishop D3 and E4
yeah White's likely to give a check
White's the king Knight they all need to
improve and quickly
and in the meantime the game between
good cash and Anish giri has started and
we'll keep you posted on any updates
there
yep still early in the game still
opening Theory between gokash and giri
we'll come to that one after this game
concludes and farrugia or look at the
clock times he's down significantly
right now but don't forget that the bone
majority on the queen side is something
special a5b4 A4 if black is able to
reach that one then he is just doing
great
yeah the white pieces need to coordinate
they need to start attacking things
together white has more pieces uh you
just struggle to get them going and okay
first to check the black king is going
to move where to you can go back it can
move to the side
perhaps far away from its Rook on a C5
and uh you told us this that if the king
and the Rook are in different colors it
can't be vulnerable to a night Fork
wow and uh just while this position gets
complicated just to rewind a few moves
here Rook to F4 would have been a killer
a Bone Crusher rooked F4 just killing
this white Bishop Hikaru could have gone
for this and look at this the White
Knight totally dominated this would have
been game over Hikaru had a winning
opportunity The Rook would simply come
to D4 and clean up the pawns but of
course this was difficult to spot
implants giving back some material
Hikaru got so confused with this
opportunity what was uh played with the
so white has three pieces for two Rooks
even though that objectively probably
black is still doing great it was really
bothering him that he blundered
something during the game right so it
got him out of the the rhythm of this
game
yeah out of the Rhythm and meanwhile
Hikaru looks back at the clock farouza
down he's about to take under a minute
against three and a half that feels
insurmountable now
white needs to get his pieces going
Bishop F2 the White Knight wants to
reroute fire G3 right now
I think Rook C3 makes a lot of sense
Andrew K3
check first even better
okay we see Brick C3 on the board
Bishop has to defund the F3 Pawn but
it's very difficult to also defend the
A2
and at the same time deal with Black's
running pawns there on the queen side
yeah and uh okay he's doing a good job
is he gonna retrieve that white light
squared Bishop now he can trap the black
Rook he's trying
pawns can roll well Rook D3 and
capturing it that's the best and
simplest way of doing it
really professional approach there
Judith and Hikaru goes for that
lean back in his chair he looks defeated
right now it feels like he's playing
playing for a draw he's fighting for his
life
and there we go The Rook gives itself up
for the bishop and pawn but Black's
pawns are surely gonna decide this game
King G6 very professional move defending
the H5 pawn and Fairuza resigns yes and
that is Hikaru who picks up a crucial
one and a half points for Asia just has
one point and you can see the
disappointment in farooja's face and
we're going to switch immediately to the
game between gukash and Anish giri and
kakash looking to see whether he's he's
close to the 40 move mark because upon
passing move 40 the players do get that
one second increment and there you see
look at this G4 was blade just in the
last move what is this lokashi has full
of energy with the porn March over there
going for the win Advance those points
uh Ivanka loves those Pawn pushes and we
love to see it too but look at that
Anish has his Knight on E5 again
always ends up there
and okay for once Anish doesn't have
Queens off early though that's the big
difference this time an F5 striking goes
energetic yeah fighting energy with
energy here white king did Shuffle to D1
that was not a mouse clip these players
are playing over the board quite simply
thinking that he needs his Rooks in the
corners that's their most active posts
and this is a safe Square for the white
king for now but it does it did do a lot
of the White's job for them you know for
instance when you attack you want to
open lines and anisha's just done that
for white but now look at that it's a
very interesting switch for Anish
playing Rook B8 he wants to go B6 and
open up the B5 because the king is C2
right now so it can be vulnerable he
thinks and he's got to be consistent
here Anish guy he's pretty much gone all
in he's going for the attack against the
white king he's even just giving up his
Central pawns just for opening up lines
here that's the currency in the position
he needs open lines towards the white
king and if you compare King safety it's
only one winner there yeah but I'm not
convinced by this turn of events I think
that go cash can simply handle this by
perhaps capturing on B6 and then using
the queen as an important Defender but
ifixan and queen B6 Queen C3 then
probably the Knight would be jumping
away to F3 or somewhere and after that
immediately Bishop E5 can be something
very unpleasant for white so maybe uh
gokash is thinking about capturing the
pawn in the center on e4
yeah he could take the other way as well
C takes B5 and start creating a passport
of his own on the a file what's he going
for so he actually takes the pawn on B5
and then grabs the pawn in the center at
this position despite what the
evaluation said Bar says it's completely
wild and oh completely neglecting King
safety good cash just simply advances
his Pawn
why not pass pawns are there to be
pushed he's paralyzed Black's rook in
the corner now the question is how safe
is that white king
yeah and uh also just to mention the
game between orientare and Magnus
Carlson has just started so we will keep
an eye on that and we will go to it
immediately after this game has finished
Judith you're the attacker of the group
do you think Anish has enough attacking
resources to hold this one well I
believe objectively white should be have
a winning position or almost winning but
there will be always kind of tricky
moves B4 B3 or C3 or knight jump or in
some way or another black maybe will
give up The Rook for on E3 The Exchange
and then play Bishop E5 so there will be
some kind of tricky moves but I'm afraid
for black having this A7 post spawn it
looks pretty awful
wow yeah cynical stuff from good cash
but effective stuff going for the queen
trade now and it might be hard to avoid
that if Queens disappear of course white
will win because of due to the Past a
pawn no more checkmates Geary's Queen
just struggles to find safe squares to
dodge this exchange well that would for
sure move away Queen E7 or something and
have uh
some counter attack or trying it out the
good thing is for black that the E5
Bishop is controlling the B8 Square so
after Queen B5 Queen B8 is not in an
immediate threat
he's gonna go for it Judith you're right
Queen E7 keeping Queens on the board
keeping any practical chances alive
the question is how to attack if white
just gets greedy just grab support on B5
well maybe Queen H4 and then after Queen
B7 Knight B4 giving up the Knight Queen
E4 check and trying to
well praying
it's the right word right now but
praying is really not a plan
just need one trick one Swindle the
problem is the players have been playing
maybe a bit too fast especially Anisha
and kakash five minutes on the clock uh
Anish hasn't asked him any real
questions over the last few moves H6
slow feels like that could be an
admission of defeat how does white
capitalize now I want to play moves like
Rook to A4 or something with the white
Rook need to get the white king to
safety
I think it's a fantastic practical move
H6
Yeah the more I look at it actually
there's still some light jumps some
night Forks that white has to be wary of
here
some pitfalls to avoid
the killer blow that's always the
hardest thing in chess how to finish
this off and kukesh wow greed is good he
argues taking another Pawn four no three
pawns up sorry right now but it feels
like more white pawns all over the place
could that be the end well it seems like
for Anish is not working out these
armageddons
and interestingly enough there haven't
been too many white victories on the r
in Armageddon we see Magnus defeated
Wesley so
but aside from that
Majora took down tarry but few are far
between
often it is black who's been successful
in the arbor Gardens this tournament
things go in waves but looks like
Black's doing great in general these
days night before that's a check but
it's just a one move threat the white
King has various safe squares to use
I like the way he shifts did that piece
to the right and a niche
well retreating the bishop
Anish two minutes on the clock he's just
trying to stay alive at this point he's
just trying to postpone the inevitable
and hope pray as Judith said that there
might be a trick A Swindle later on this
is
n't to be a fortress even though
and he really wants to have a real
Fortress there tonight and the bishop
and the queen but there is three pawns
down which which makes it quite
difficult
three pawns down and once white
activates the Rook or gets the king even
further to safety uh it's likely that
anisha's defenses will eventually
crumble first he can activate the queen
he slides back I like pinky too a lot
going to a white square when black has a
black Square Bishop at the same time of
course the pawn on H5 can be vulnerable
yeah black is threatening to capture
that white H5 Pawn with a check not the
biggest threat in the world but at least
it will make good cash pause
maybe the nerves will start to settle if
he can't finish this uh off in the next
20 or so moves
it's no longer kind of Gary survives the
more chances he will have later on
yes the big problem is the existence of
this Pawn on A7 you cannot shake away
that one because the White Queen can
come and to defend no he's actually
defended that with his Pawn
is Rook there sorry Rook yeah Rook to H1
passive square but it's good enough and
how can a niche get through with this
queen his Queen is the only piece that
can really move right now Anish but a
good squares for her
oh yeah tough situation as black three
pawns down almost paralyzed
okay Queen to f8
door no threat on the board we will
centralize itself to E4
troll over everything
no he's actually moving The Rook up
so this one looks like there's no hope
whatsoever for a niche so shall we Dash
over and check the Armageddon game
between Anish sorry Ariane and Magnus
this game is again still early days but
there have been some well there has been
some drama a niche not a niche sorry
Ariane this time has just sacrificed a
piece and he's trying to get to that
black king both of Black's Knights are
under threat right now going for
magnus's King
oh and we just see the evaluation bar
slide in favor of black and Magnus
jumping in with his Knight it looks like
this operation was not a good idea for
Ariane and we see a bad Bishop again
yesterday in against Nakamura tari was
suffering in the classical game from a
very bad A7 bishop and look at that he
has the same kind of Bishop only from
the right side
yeah that time it was bad Bishop against
good night and it looks like it could be
good night in this game too if black
does get time now for Rook G8 this is a
beautiful piece uh on F4 it might cost
quite a rook okay Aaron slides across
with his Queen but what to do
this black Rook is simply coming a check
on F6 can simply be blocked Rook G7
looks like one-way counter play right
now with Judith you mentioned one bad
piece makes the whole position bad this
bishop is terrible
well white is in big trouble has to
defend over G2 but also the D3 Pawn is
under attack and it's gonna be taken one
of them
maybe it's is it time to throw caution
to the wind grab the knights and
oh there's no way to actually activate
the light Square Bishop so
yeah big trouble actually how are you
going to defend the G2 Pawn because if
you step forward with the Rook to F2
then the Knight will grab the H3 pawn
and that is all over for white
well probably with white I would still
try to go King H1 and try to give up the
G2 but I think uh Magnus will be not so
nice to take that pawn but the four
and that has provoked a capture of a
pawn from Magnus Carlson Knight's Pawn
is a check the King has to move now uh
you want to slide in the corner now can
you activate the queen with E4
wow that would be a lovely move just
pushing the queen and pulling forward to
trying to get the queen in the black
queen is however tied down to the
defense of her Rook on d8 so gotta be
slightly careful maybe just still very
good though that Ivanka feels like
there's something in the air for black
that white king is the more vulnerable
of the two
but two threats Paul takes Knight and a
capture on E5 threatened by white
how to deal with them both
maybe you have to give something up to
get something
well there is a way of maybe giving mate
what about the Rook D6 Queen E5 Rook H6
[Music]
37 Knight F4 G2 mate beautiful Magnus
surely can't resist he loves the queen
sacrifice uh root D6 Rook H6 the
question is that after Rook D6 maybe
Queen H4 can be a saver
it might be a savior
but uh well Ariane doesn't have too much
time to figure it out and it's magnus's
move will he play Rook D6 no he Retreats
the Knight again very practical decision
okay but a bit of a Grimace on magnus's
face when he went for this night Retreat
Ariane brings this Rook across trying to
escape
I don't understand
I think he just saw no hope in that end
game 46 and it's uh
it's over the Checkmate without giving
up the queen
Magnus is going to deliver Checkmate
once the White Queen takes on E5 the
black Rook comes to H6 and as Judith
says there's going to be Knight checks
and a forced mate on the board Magnus
looks way he knows he's got it in the
back two minutes is more than enough to
finish this game off
uh Ariana I think he has some chances
earlier but we'll see a Checkmate maybe
on the board now that's a check another
night check wherever the white king goes
Knight F4
this is over absolutely uh impressive
game by Magnus he really knows how to
level up when he needs to and Magnus
going back to his winning ways do we
think we'll see Ariana allow the
Checkmate on the board
there we go he drops his note back and
all white can do to postpone the
inevitable is oh my God
Magnus was about to make an illegal move
he wanted to checkmate with his Rook but
the Rook was pinned
instead he just swaps Queens first next
move
and well very impressive game by Magnus
Carlson winning the in the Armageddon
with the black pieces but it was also a
good day for gookash who won the
Armageddon match against Anish Geary
with the white pieces he looked like he
was in full control
and that concludes a very I have to say
turbulent round you know in the
classical games it looked very solid
very safe but in the Armageddon it was
like the player's creativity was let
loose
yeah we need to catch our breath there's
just so much action simultaneous
Armageddon games how's anyone supposed
to keep up with that but it was dramatic
it was fun and instructive actually how
kukesh clinched his game we see the
players discussing the closing stages or
maybe uh some of the action from a bit
earlier let's zoom in to show how gukesh
did uh get the uh extra point extra half
point there in the Armageddon this was
the final position you might ask how did
the pawn get to D7 how did Pawn get to
H7 what happened to White's A7 Pawn
let's uh go back we left it around at
this point after Queen to E8 white
simply dropped back with the king queen
A4 trying to sneak around the back this
was shut up shut down by King to G2
simply and Rook to H1 this black queen
is kicked back where she came from no
safe squares other than A4 and Bishop
takes H6 beautiful blow here if the
bishop is captured then there would be a
checkmating attack starting with this uh
Queen Slide the black king is not going
to survive here for much longer instead
Anish had to just accept that he could
take the a pawn and a few moves down the
line the H porn was the runner
all the way down the board and a few
moves later the D Pawn was the runner
discovered attack against The Rook
hitting black from all angles this one
is simply over the black queen had to
walk back she was forced onto the back
Rank and the last move Rook to C1 all
the pawns now running forward and Rook
C8 is the killer blue what a beautiful
victory
yeah I I like the fact that you cash
he's so brave he he's not afraid of
dynamism he's not afraid of sacrificing
he just simply was bold and played a
fantastic game against Gary and we've
seen that often with Kakashi just levels
up when it comes to the Armageddon chest
he just lets the initiative and his
creative creative juices just flow and
let's have a look at today's scores uh
orientari losing in the Armageddon to
Magnus Carlson and basically four games
out of five all were had to be decided
by Armageddon there were some wild ones
alireza farouza also crashing out to
Hikaru Nakamura but it was tournament
leader Fabiana caruana who walked away
with a very important classical win
netting three points
oh what a what an exciting day
wow I was not expecting this that today
we are going to witness nine games and
what a nine nine games and it was so
interesting with gokash actually that
today he was marching with five past
spawns because in the in the classical
game also he had he reached out to A6
and B6 on the nagananish and here he has
three postpones he could not Queen it
any of them but he could win the match
but uh fantastic amazing day yeah
absolutely amazing and David what were
your highlights
where to start it has to be all the
armageddon's all happening at once uh
Hikaru just the calmness the speed the
kind of strength there that he showed
and yeah gokesh just a master class I
think saying to everyone at home when in
doubt push those pawns it might uh reap
you might reap the rewards and let's
talk about Fabiano's performance because
that game was really tense it was caging
very blocked and then suddenly it got
wild
yeah it got wild and just Fabi even
though he had kind of not too much time
on the clock he navigated he calculated
extremely well that's why we kind of
praised fabi's calculation skills
because even with limited time when
things sharpen up he's always ready but
yeah just the Poise and the kind of
bounce back ability to come back from a
heartbreaking defeat yesterday and um
against the dangerous opponent like
Abdul satoroff when it was so tense
impressive stuff he's really in grateful
and Fabi he really is and that Victory
with the black pieces against 18 year
old nordebec abdicator propels him into
a huge lead it almost seems
insurmountable at this time he walked
away with an extra three points so he is
now on 13 and a half points out of 18.
Hikaru Nakamura well he needs to start
winning some classical games with still
two and a half points behind him with 11
points and alireza farouza and gukash
eight and a half points and for
four-time winner is actually a five-time
winner but he won it four times in a row
Magnus Carlsen he's languishing in sixth
place with seven and a half points out
of 18. he really needs to pull a string
of Victories together in the end
and wow Fabiana carwana Hikaru Nakamura
all providing us entertainment but I
guess that's kind of should be expected
because these are the world's most
fighting players and uh here we're going
to see Tuesday's matchups and we see
Magnus Carlsen with the white pieces
against Ali Reza farouza someone that he
himself hand-picked as a potential
future award Championship Challenger and
then Wesley so nordebec Abdul sotorov
what excites you about these encounters
Judith I have to tell you that I think I
I'm very much eager to see Magnus if he
is running out of time because tomorrow
is I think the last moment where he can
start winning his classical games and
score three points immediately otherwise
he is not going to win the tournament
yeah and for you David I mean we see
Fabiana caruana facing off against good
cash
yeah you uh picked the game that I'm
most Keen to follow we have the leader
against arguably the most impressive
young player uh in the world right now
gokesh just so impressive in the
Armageddon and there we see Magnus
having a last minute interview with
Norwegian television Ariane as well
staying behind uh to share his thoughts
really nice to see some sportsmanship
the players uh yeah just doing their bit
for Chester for the chess public it's
it's actually great to see the power the
players are willing to give those
interviews immediately after they
finished and for Ariane there with a big
smile on his face after suffering quite
a painful defeat there in Armageddon
he's languishing in bottom place it's a
tough experience for him
well it's always very tough to play
against Magnus and I think in the
classical game they had a very good
fight and at some point after the middle
game he was on the edge of having
trouble but somehow he saved it so I
think there he can be happy and he was
satisfied of course the Armageddon what
we've seen from the middle of it he did
not have so much chance to save that
game yeah and for you David for
armageddon's one classical win what's
been your highlight
all of the armageddons but for me I'm
most looking forward to the final
stretch it's the last three rounds now
last three games and for everyone
chasing Fabiano it's time to take risks
even more risks than we've already seen
and that only promises more action yes
and it's gonna be all about risk taking
taking in the final rounds and as the
curtain falls on another exhilarating
day at Norway chess I'd like to thank
everyone at home for watching us and
remember same time same place 5 PM
Central European Time so see you
tomorrow
foreign